one two three
hello friends
as always
comment first image
and let us know
that's not working so
i completely like screwed up john this
morning trying to like crop out the
lower area and then that's the very
first thing you'll see so tell us if we
are live as long as you can hear us we
are good to go
konichiwa tell us if you can hear us
from lucifer and if you can hear us i
would love it if you could go ahead hit
that like button can we make this chat a
little bit bigger on our end john or
zory to like punch it in looks really
cool command plus doesn't it command
plus maybe
command plus hold on guys there we go
that's good of it is if you if you zoom
into one youtube window you have to zoom
into all of these
so
needing the super chats to be huge
deontay jose faith helena what's going
on we got some people coming in here
loud and clear
i saw freddy krueger josh rosalie's
josh jones all right guys so before we
start kicking off this stream start
a hit that like button b
to start telling give quick thoughts in
the chat quick thoughts in the chat of
what you guys think
of this uh movie quick thoughts on what
you thought of the movie really really
fast really
spitball it out we waited till monday
today's labor day in the states is labor
day a uh
it's a national holiday every like banks
and stuff are closed but is it like
worldwide yes globally they celebrated
every country
including uganda is that [ __ ] you
guys are messing with me i'm still
waking up
i don't know the theme of the live
stream
i was just joking
hey it's shara
i don't know what she's doing here
do you like having that info up there
all right the time and all that later oh
my god no john get rid of it that was my
fault
we might check out james james my
malignant chong cheese incredible looks
like most people are actually really
enjoying this movie quite a bit hey man
it made a lot a lot a lot a lot of money
okay cool made a couple bucks achara
just trying to steal attention from the
chat right now or is that someone posing
as a charger it's more likely someone
posing as a charm well that's even
because she's got [ __ ] to do all right
guys well you guys control this stream
in more ways than you realize you guys
dictate the way this conversation goes
i'm loving hearing how many of you guys
really enjoyed this movie um i saw it
twice you saw it twice i saw it twice
two times you saw it twice two john did
you did you like it more the second time
john or or less the second time
i liked it it went down didn't it it
went down a lot for you that's right i
hated you you were like i thought i
liked asian people i don't think i saw
this higher asian community of the world
any longer uh no no i i definitely
enjoyed it this second time i walked out
of the theater going i like asian people
now i don't know why it's weird i walked
out of the second uh viewing having
enjoyed the movie more i thought it was
a smoother experience overall but i do
have like a clearer picture of my
overall opinion i guess so in terms of
like knowing what my criticisms would be
i have a better idea of those now
um but uh yeah especially on second
viewing just knowing what's coming i
thought it played smoother that's
exactly what i said yeah thank you guys
for the super chats are coming and we'll
get to them in a minute you know how we
do this is how it goes we interact with
the live stream chat and then we're like
no let's earn our way to get into the
super chats then we go to the super
chats the people in the live stream chat
get a little bit annoyed with us
how come you're only talking about the
super chats
we're trying to talk about the parts not
the super chats
but yeah we got stream labs which takes
less of a cut by the way if you guys do
want to contribute craig's all about the
money that's it that's all i've ever
heard up at the top that's why he only
talks about the super chat i don't even
know anything about marvel if you're
into
streamlabs link pinned up at the top and
in the description box if there was a
time where it doesn't feel like an mcu
movie what was clear for me oh
christine's watching for the third time
tonight nice there was um it's a spoiler
top people were saying please no
spoilers it literally says spoiler
toggle in the title and the thumbnail
too
the whole point why we're here you can't
be here okay if it's spoilers so if you
don't want anything spoiled for you
don't be here this is the last place you
need to be black panther kills
killmonger oh yeah it's really dark so i
really i i think that um i liked it a
lot more the second time i think it
played a lot smoother for me the second
time and i didn't notice when i don't
feel something that's the best way i can
describe when i start to not feel
something because i'm really into the
first half of this movie a lot and
that's when wen wu after wen wu shows up
after uh shanghi fights with the death
dealer
and then they're taken back to the um
where's that place called the tao lo no
no no talo is where the mom's from the
uh where the where the ten rings
organization is
or where he or one move lives right that
home china
yeah it goes back to china
and then after their their dinner
it's around that time where i start to
get it starts to feel a little too
bogged down and they're kind of just
explaining stuff to me whether it be
backstory they're just kind of saying
stuff or they're just giving exposition
dumps a lot of the time
um
after the wenwood dinner with everyone
which is a great scene that i really
like where they're talking about like
with aquafina katie and like what a real
chinese name is and all that like i'm
enjoying all that information
but then it's like they get thrown into
the jail
and then ben kingsley's there all of a
sudden and it's like oh how are we going
to get to tahloe well fortunately ben
kingsley has this little guy who will
know how are we going to get out of jail
bam right away super easy barely an
inconvenience yeah the sister's like i
know the way out of the tunnels
and then it's like yeah it's a little
bit funny went with the whole like
planet of the apes bit that they were
doing i think there's a funny moment but
then there's this i don't know there's
something about when they finally get to
tallow or i'm not really feeling much i
got excited when michelle yofer shows up
but then michelle yo just i don't feel
like we really got to know her as a
person or a character she just kind of
becomes another
exposition character like right away
that's the beauty of michelle yo though
is that she can just show up and deliver
lines and it works
for me yeah no i think she works i think
she's great i mean michelle yo she's
good yeah but i i was kind of just i was
i was not really feeling much that's all
i'm going to say is like i don't think i
don't like it's like i feel like they
could have done all that same stuff but
just
a bit of a different execution to still
have the emotional undertones going on
as opposed to i'm just i've just been
digesting information for like 20 to 30
minutes straight right versus actually
feeling
true emotional investment in what's
going on right i get it you you hate
michelle yo i understand yeah but then
when it goes back to the flashbacks when
it like when you see uh the truth of the
mom
and like how she died that night and how
shang chi was there and witnessed his
mom being killed when it goes back to
that that's when i got really pulled
back into the movie again so it was
really just like a 20 i think that 20 to
30 minute chunk
kind of overshadowed some of my first
experience but the second time around i
i wasn't as bothered by it i would say
me neither yeah because yeah that the
most in the movie i really i really do
enjoy a lot yeah uh for me the second
time around i didn't notice any slowdown
actually at all because whatever was
slowing down for me in the first
experience i was i didn't feel that
whatsoever it actually moved along and i
think it's because of what john said
which is
i knew what to expect so i just had a
lot more fun with it i was able to pay
attention to things i didn't pay
attention to the first time around i
didn't even notice like you because you
kept saying how much you love the music
and i kept hearing that a lot i didn't
even notice the music the first time
around to be honest with you i got to
pay attention to it this time and i
actually appreciated ben kingsley way
more this time than i did the first time
because i thought he was just a major
distraction the first time but because i
knew he was coming i got to enjoy his
presence more well and in the second
viewing it was like every time i would
be like ah you know i'm starting to feel
the pace or the run time then he would
show back up with some levity at like
just the right exactly yeah so uh and
yeah i feel like that was it for me is
the second time there were moments where
i could feel like this movie has a so
much to do and half of me is like great
uh job at
like there's so many really short scenes
there's a lot of information to get out
and for what those really short scenes
are i think they're handled really well
with a lot of poise but
and i feel like this is gonna become my
new marvel movie complaint is just like
there's so much it has to squeeze in to
this amount of time that it is like a
thick movie that yeah at times it does
feel like oh man i'm a little
overwhelmed and i want a scene to go on
for a little longer or something but
like
one of my biggest complaints the first
time was like oh in the third act it
becomes it's like this kaiju movie takes
over and i didn't feel that way the
second time actually uh yeah i i still
felt that but less okay yeah it was it
just it just moved along a lot quicker
the second time because like you you had
a sense as to what was coming yeah you
know it's like i think that's you kind
of got two movies slapped into one here
you got the first movie which is about
shanghai trying to escape from his past
and then his father's coming for him
and then the second half is like
when woo's movie when moo wants to go to
tahloe and then he feels like his wife
is calling back to him from the dead so
it's war with hollow all of a sudden
it's like it's like two different movies
slapped into one and i prefer that first
half but that's not to say there's parts
in the second half that i really do
enjoy a lot like even with the dragon
stuff and like the mega soul sucker i
was like
i feel like this movie maybe didn't need
that
but it's still so cool to look at it was
one of those things and usually like
being so cool to look at doesn't
eliminate
a criticism for me and not that it fully
eliminates it but it actually
uh softens it more to the point where i
liked it more the second time around
because of that moment in the do you
want to say something oh and i just
thought the birthday was good maria
thank you i thought that bolstered also
too like you know because we have
certain characters where people have
debated like how did what do they bring
into the avengers really like i thought
having the kaiju stuff at the end and
having especially the way shanghi is
like running along the back of it and
like doing all this stuff like it helps
to elevate him above like okay he's got
all the martial arts mastery and can
hang when like supernatural craziness
goes down you know right uh one of my
complaints when i watched it was that
the first half was so amazing and then
the second half loses a lot of that like
cool martial arts
it's not well it's not as focused but
like i felt like it lost a lot of that
martial arts in the second half the
first time i watched it watching at this
time i got to pay attention to more you
know fine details from the fight scenes
in the latter half especially between
shang china's father and i got to
appreciate it more i still came out
going oh i wish it was longer i wish it
was more emphasized i wish there was
like a battle with the dragon with them
and the rings something like that where
the father you see the father turn to
the good side and actually try to fight
kind of like i hate to reference this
but kylo ren at the end of star wars
like i see him turn and fight for good
before he gets taken out by the dragon
yeah that would have been dope but it's
like the moment he turns like that
moment he has that switch he's out which
is kind of frustrating it felt like a
lost opportunity you know that's a
common thing even cosmic wonder said
that he thought that there should have
been more of an extra beat with wen wu
yeah uh before he died but i personally
really both times i've seen it i'm like
no i kind of prefer like what you just
said is pretty much a warren said too
and i'm like no i actually don't mind it
in that moment because this guy is just
he's descended so far
that he's gotten so and then i think in
that moment he realized like
one thing i love about that fight with
shang chi well
we're gonna i'm reading all the cards
i'm doing the thing where we're talking
i'm reading everyone's comments in the
stream yeah yeah and i'm aware their
super chat's coming in so we're gonna
get to all that we can't talk we can't
go too deep dive vigorously overshadow
some questions that have been coming in
right but one thing that i i actually
didn't notice until the second time
around was like i love that first fight
between shang chi's mom and wen wu in
the very beginning how they're like
falling in love with each other over the
course of this fight yeah and then in
the in the fight with wen wu and shang
chi i didn't even notice it until the
second time
was when when he is using like more of
his mother's technique shanxi they do a
mirror shot from the first fight with
the mom yeah and then it's like that
where you could see when woo
seeing his uh seeing his wife and his
son you know what i mean yeah and so i
think in that moment when he does
when he is consumed by the mega soul
sucker
it's all visual with his eyes i guess i
pick up on all the body language of
what's going on underneath is like he
realizes after that mega soul sucker
comes out he even saved shang qi from
getting killed by him and then he lets
his fight be a sword and the whole time
he was like maybe my son can earn the
ten rings that's a big part of what move
wants to do so he then he relinquishes
the power and allows himself to die yeah
yeah so i realized powerful i don't
think he needed an extra a lot of people
do though like you know a lot of people
do and i i just don't yeah i think i
think i needed it for the plot for the
just for the story and i think it needed
that extra momentum see that's where i
just
that's where i actually disagree with
you though because i feel like it does
achieve what it needs to for the plot in
the story in that he looks at shang qi
and recognizes oh wow yeah i was wrong
on this one and you were absolutely
right and yeah and in all in that yeah
split second all that character stuff
came back for me
i i got more emotional the second time i
liked it a lot i did i i i pretty much i
i preferred it the second time i watch
it um a lot more um
no you see dreamline in the chat saying
katie sucks sorry but not sorry k you
know katie seems to be a lot of people
uh most of people on this channel have
been saying they really like katie a lot
i was kind of worried she might be
aquafina i thought she might yeah i
loved aquafina i thought she might be
chris tucker and rush hour 3.
i liked her
so she wasn't she was great for me like
tony liang and aquafina were the stand
out for me
and and that was on the first viewing on
the second viewing i appreciated both of
them even more which i didn't know was
possible like getting to focus in on
aquafina's expressions and seeing her
face also like i think the theater you
took us to
was a better projection than where we
saw it the first time cinema yes and so
i really got to i really got to hone in
on aquafina's face and her expressions
every little nuance um there were some
parts where i was like oh that's a
little bit much but overall i thought
she brought she had a great presence i
never thought she went overboard no yeah
and even the arrow thing i thought
played better the second time for me
yeah i like that the first and the
second time i thought it was fine
i thought it was fine
i thought it was fine only because it's
not the crippling blow it just helps out
and it's like she spends so much time
waiting for the right shot that i'm like
okay they've established that she can
drive cars really well surely she could
shoot an arrow and a dragon
the exact same thing
everyone in the village only katie was
someone who could fire the air hey mccar
aim and arrow what's the
yeah it's not perfect yeah i liked it
better
um but okay but there's a theory like
maddie's pointing out in the chat right
now and then we'll hop on to the some of
the super chats in a second
um
uh let's see here what katie is the
granddaughter the gang leader who killed
shang's mother willing to bet is
confirmed in the sequel i'm not sure i
mean i did wonder about that actually
they invented quite a few characters for
this movie like this is this
this story is very different than
chongqi's actual origin in the comics
just so i have clarification what was
just said the guy that shang chi kills
who killed his mom is connected to
aquafina's character
uh maybe potentially sure i'm not i
thought they were going to reveal that
in the movie and it just never came up i
feel like in the sequel the person who
chongqi killed is probably i don't know
if he's actually dead or not i don't
know for some feeling that my black
widow would a little bit
naughty is dead
he comes back as fu manchu in the sequel
doesn't have to feel guilty about
killing him anymore it's perfect um
let's see here good retcon what did you
think about what did you think about
them not showing that scene where shanxi
kills him i think it would have been too
much because we need to sell toys
i i thought they pussed it out a little
bit there we absolutely remember you
jenna and the stars you're saying the
audio is really off the guy in the
middle mic is way louder all right
john do your adjustments my friend what
if i talk like this the entire time it's
like i guess
how you doing everybody's coming to
disney it's costing i think 40 days
exactly how's everybody feeling out
there
all right i don't know why y'all hanging
out if you haven't seen the movie yet
it's a spoiler talk
we're just adjusting the audio a little
bit
who is josh
who is here
is better hell no i've no i've never
warmed up to that movie hey jenna
which movie have you not warmed up to
romeo must die you never get on board
with it try it try now anthony
hey there hello how's everybody doing
i'm uh talking at a normal voice
and just enjoying my time here with my
bro and his bro i mean no john lee and
chongqi are connected to the dragon i
think the movie makes that really clear
that makes it that makes it really clear
holy [ __ ]
all right cool audio is fine all right
uh all right guys let's move on to some
of these super chess thank you guys so
much for being here all right
i did like the race you know it's funny
the last thing we really talk about are
the rings i thought the rings were cool
i thought
what kind of surprise what i think we're
going to learn more with the rings
themselves is that you know how in like
in the comics the rings do have
individual powers whereas here they all
kind of seem to it's a little bit
ambiguous what exactly they do but they
all have some type of energy force thing
going on but they're all similar the
rings
um i think maybe as the rings get more
understood and unlocked we're gonna see
that there are more individual powers
within them but i thought overall they
were used really cool they're not not my
favorite part of the fights but they i
thought they were used to great effect
and i like when shang chi
uses the uses it to destroy the mega
soul sucker by putting it inside and
then
lifting it out i did enjoy that that was
cool looking but i still really wanted
him to punch it
i wanted to see him punch it like like
goku style just
punch it
like right in the kisser so guys in the
chat where would you rank this movie in
the marvel mcu what would top 10 10 to
20.
definitely the top comment with your
complete yeah
all the list the entire listen there i'm
at your completed rankings now it's
definitely up there i love watching the
fight scenes in the first half yeah i
think they're so cool um that that um
uh bus fight like made me appreciate uh
simulu's uh i messed up his name simulu
i appreciated the actors ability to
replicate jackie chan's movement in
moving through the bus and stuff like
that especially the moment when he he
falls into the driver's seat it was just
so graceful i'm like dang that's it
looks so damn good oh yeah the way he's
jumping up and through the hand bars and
stuff yep we got the super chats up it
is time we gotta move it along but
everyone in the chat's been saying top
ten i'm 99 percent of people have been
saying top ten all right who's the first
one that we got today thank you
thank you so much for contributing to
the super chats by the way
the audio was fine when she was here at
the stream so i don't know that one
person was talking to someone said all
right who's the first person we got
fastie donates a moment of silence thank
you fastie thank you fast moment of
silence miles that's what those are now
miles dorsey how's it going miles dorsey
thank you very much for your generosity
and kindness my favorite part was shong
exploding the dragon and the
post-credits scene i'm guessing she-hulk
will explain why bruce is bruce and
happy belated birthday thank you miles i
really appreciate that he's got stuff
all over his wrist he's got like a thing
with the green light on it you know on
the other side where he doesn't have a
sling on some some technological is
keeping bruce in stasis i talk about
bruce banner specifically
i was looking at his wrists the second
time well there's i believe emil blonsky
abomination is supposed to show up in
the she-hulk series
and if i'm understanding correctly the
director did say that one of the
mandatory things required by marvel was
to include the wong versus abomination
thing which makes sense i thought it it
works well because when you're going
into xiling's world you're like okay all
right she's got fighting going on so you
sure we could have this like fun little
easter egg here and have cameo
appearance of abomination versus wong
um but
what what struck me as a bit odd was
that abomination never turned back into
emil blonsky even though wong does call
him a meal at one point
so it's like okay clearly has a
connection to him so it's kind of
interesting to me that
hulk found some way maybe through magic
connecting with wong some type of
sorcery where he was able to go back
from being hulk into bruce banner
but maybe abomination stuck in this form
maybe it's a budgetary thing
that it's cheaper to
have hulk is just regular bruce banner
instead of hulk no i don't think they
would i think it was such a big part of
the plot for avengers end game that they
would have uh that hulk was he was stuck
in that form or he found a way to fuse
into that form so he must have made some
choice to go back to that form i think
tim tim roth is the one who played
abomination right yeah apparently he
really showed up for
shanghai to do his role in that yeah
exactly that's why i thought like why
didn't he ever go back into a mill
blonsky forum
and it looked like when he brought
when when after he does the sling ring
wong and then you see behind didn't look
it was back to the sanctum santorum
looked like it was like at the rapture
yeah and the chat have been saying the
raft too it looked like the raft maybe
he's borrowing him and like leaving a
projection fake abomination just to fool
any security yeah
and also bruce banner's age like 25
years
that snap took a lot out of them shouts
to scrabbzilla54 said the removal
redressing of the jacket was awesome big
meals on wheels vibes
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wheels on meals hold on which part uh
the removal and redressing of the jacket
and the bus fight mm-hmm
i don't remember that in wheels
i don't remember that in wheels on meals
i remember it in a bunch of jackie chan
movies yeah yeah in general that's a
very good thing but like i don't
remember it specifically in wheels on
meals like i'd have to go back and watch
it it's actually wheels on meals because
then china they were saying that uh or
hong kong they were saying that and the
movies that start with m don't do well
so they change it to wheels that's a
true story
that's a very accurate reason actually i
looked it up too that's why there's not
a mr mrs smith too uh freddie ruger
freddie ruger hey guys i watched the
movie yesterday and i gotta tell you
it's my third favorite behind end game
and infinity war now i wouldn't put it
that high for me
i'm probably like
if i were to guess without going through
all the movies i'd say it's somewhere
between five through ten for me but not
real but not top five i wouldn't say
it's top five it might be number five
yeah but yeah i would say five through
ten is a safe safe place end game's
still definitely my favorite thanks for
stopping by joshua yeah i'd say end game
still definitely my favorite um
but i i like did i i mean there's some
people who love this so much john
campios watches six times
which is a lot that's a lot yeah
viewings warren's like it's not
it it's
uh
it's it's not uh wait dream lion says
thanksgiving losing my [ __ ] on these
opinions what the hell does that mean
it's like freaking out every time you
drop an opinion just like oh
new ideas
it didn't seem overtly bad so i was like
you know maybe this guy just loves your
opinions and every time i'm not over
praising it and i don't feel like i'm i
i feel like i'm pretty fair when it
comes to talking about this movie um
yeah what were we just saying your
favorite movies
yeah it's somewhere in the top it's
number five through ten yeah i saw it
nine times and then freaking uh warren's
like it's not just one of the best
marvel movies it's one of the best
movies ever and i there are a lot of
people who are so in love with this and
i'm so happy that people are absorbing
it uh not absolutely receiving it this
well uh but for for me i
i don't know it's like somewhere within
five through ten i wouldn't say it's one
of my favorite movies of all time but i
would say it's in the top 5 through 10
for marvel you know what it might be is
that you and i grew up with those kinds
of movies and so maybe yeah it's like
we've been watching martial arts like
non-stop since we were little kids so
that might have an effect on our level
of appreciation for it we're like it's
cool like you know yeah because we can
see what it's like referencing yeah like
we that we have it works on that
nostalgic factor for us yeah exactly
yeah um so yeah that's what i would say
definitely like it might be number five
for me but hey venom has another new
release date thanks chris
thanks for the heads up
they're like
didn't break 200 million opening weekend
we gotta push this
uh i love one move versus zhang lee
showing the story and fight
josh wren thank you sir i love that the
story of that fight is my favorite yeah
like it's not my favorite fight in the
movie but the story of it is so good
because that is some of my favorite
visual storytelling within that film
where a movie that has a lot of very
overt world building and character
moments where they're like kind of
saying everything
that fight itself i think everyone who
watches that first fight you're like oh
damn they're falling for each other like
you could just
in this one fight you're watching
because you they set it up so well where
when woo has been conquering for decades
or centuries by this point he's been
kicking ass left and right nothing is a
challenge for him so of course he's
going to fall in love with the one woman
who can kick his ass right you know
it's such a good story of the fight when
that fight showed up i appreciate it
even uh again like just as much as i did
the first time the thing that i realized
i really didn't want was as that the
narrative exposition as much i know that
they had to do that to get you up to
speed but it's like it's when she said
that's when the first time i met your
father i wish that line came at the end
of the fight instead of the beginning of
the fight because you already know
what's going to happen in the fight
didn't it come at the end no it came at
the camera i thought i said that's why i
met your father and then it cuts to her
holding the baby
i don't know i'm pretty i just wish that
dialogue wasn't in there at all just
like having me have the fight and then
let's come in with the narration and all
that stuff or just have less of it but
that fight i to me was up on par with
what you got from yoon woo ping like in
crouching tiger and i thought it was
really really well done because you see
a lot of imitators that never measure up
to like okay la la land for instance is
a is an imitation of like hollywood
films of yester sure right but it
doesn't measure up to that whereas this
totally measures up to crouching tiger
and all that stuff
in my opinion so definitely up there is
one of my favorite fight scenes from
american films in general all right john
take away the next one thank you josh
ren all right quang min
i am burmese oh really quick really
quick so sorry okay venom moved to
october first yes in the chat i just
verified i thought i got i think i
pushed later all right okay cool good to
know good to know all the headlines are
like shang chi's big success venom moves
up there you go i told you everything
was depending on this movie i'm not the
only one who said that
most people did all right so take it
away john variants be damned
i am burmese not chinese but i am happy
for my asian brothers and sisters making
it to the superhero to the big superhero
movie but jackie chan and jetley are
still my childhood heroes
yeah we to see them get into the mcu
next i would love to see jackie chan
join this
gently can't fight anymore yeah did you
notice michelle yo was replaced
sometimes
uh sometimes it looked like she had a
stunt double or the lighting was
revealing that she's really in her 60s
yeah
she's 59 years old so they had to do a
face replacement on the stunt double but
like she's still held her own for the
most part i mean yeah on the shots where
it's clearly her she can still move
really well yeah yeah i thought she was
great i mean we we watched a lot of
michelle you when we were younger heroic
trio what was it what was the sequel
that the r word
i can't remember which i didn't like the
sequel as much which movie would jackie
chan where she did that crazy motorcycle
stuff super cop
thank you kwang thank you and we got
next rhythmsie games i saw yesterday
with my brother and i absolutely loved
it it'll i'll probably go again tomorrow
with my friend and since she wanted to
see it as well working on uploading my
review soon as my film on my film
channel can't wait to see that review
man yeah keep it up keep up the good
work rhythm z this is one of those
movies where people are like even for
for for me i was like i'm taking my mom
mom has to watch it she likes it she
likes you liked it a lot yeah mom liked
it a lot my mom's usually like it's okay
that's usually her response to every
movie but she didn't like it as much as
her sister though but when i watched it
after it was done i was like did you
like it and she's like yeah she's like
she looked really happy with the movie
and i and it was that effect of like
it's because you're [ __ ] asian
look everyone's asian here i see myself
now you know how i feel at most movies
such prizes
look at us look at us killing the game
achieving the annoying ranter thank you
hey buddy annoying ranter how much does
a new asian american iron fist team up
with shang qi would slap
a lot in my opinion uh uh a
a new asian american iron fist teaming
up with shang qi would that slap do you
guys think that would be a fire move
look they got to replace finn jones that
like is he caucasian in the comics
yes yeah finn jones
i think jones is caucasian in the
comments you could get a good white guy
to do fin like it doesn't need to be age
okay
[ __ ] the the stunt coordinator the
second human director on this is brad
allen who's a white dude who was on
jackie chan stunt team so right he was
on his actual stunt team yes yeah yes
and he's an amazing martial artist and
he was one of the few who like he's like
the only white guy who was ever on
jackie chan
yes and uh australian also to be fair
yeah that's true yeah so i think that
what does that have to do with anything
because they're the craziest white
people
but so yeah i mean i i guess as cool as
it would be to see an asian american
take up the mantle of iron fist and and
like a movie or something like that um i
think it's not impossible to find a dude
who you because because
simu liu
was uh he was trained by andy lee from
marshall club that i i didn't know we
didn't know this until we i had no idea
i thought he was a real fighter but
there's been hours and hours for for
months on that's brad allen brought in
um andy lee
andy lee trained him and also became
death dealer in the movie and uh also
helpful
because has a background in parkour but
not in martial arts so he still had to
train him how to move him so it was
hours and hours point being is i thought
simu was a real martial artist yeah he
moved so well that not one part of me
was like this guy was clearly training
for like he he moves flawlessly to the
point where i didn't think it was
i didn't think like oh he he had to be
trained i thought they hired someone
with a martial arts background for it i
thought death dealer got shafted pretty
hard oh yeah
i felt it even more the second time i'm
like damn they're really shy
especially being the first to get soul
sucked like come on you made a good
poster though can we refresh the chat
here yes actually really quick uh faith
gettys has a great question who would
you guys like to see shangchi team up
with spiderman answering the chat
captain marvel yeah
why not
uh yes we are biological brothers john
and i have been brothers since birth
yeah that's right
uh and yes brad allen has since passed
rest in peace
i met him once did i tell you that yeah
i met him once at uh gymnastics olympica
he's a very quiet demeanor and very very
nice i freaking flipped out when i saw
him like are you are you brad allen he's
like yes i am
very kind that was a great that was a
lovely impression yeah i wish he had
more all right so uh who else we got
here francis dionysio thank
thank you so much man that's a really
generous super chat thank you dude i've
thrown up a peace sign and a punch and a
kick super effective nice that's a fun
little uh sticker i've never seen it
before i hope everybody got a chance to
enjoy i think i think they should bring
back death dealer or flush them out in
some way again because yeah i mean
someone can do some voodoo
it seemed like they were building for
some real personal showdown with him and
then it never went there yeah yeah do
you remember brad pitt i mean not brad
pitt but uh quentin tarantino's
explanation of why brad pitt was able to
beat bruce lee in once upon a time
in hollywood trying not to kill him well
no i mean the whole thing was
establishing that that's how badass brad
pitt's character was right and so i
thought maybe likewise here it's to show
how like frightening these soul suckers
are it's like they took out death dealer
yeah i thought that was the point
but i didn't like it
that's fair you know i'm sorry you
understand the comparison yeah totally
okay he's brad he's bruce lee and and
yeah once upon a time
the incredible
um did you thank you the incredible did
you saw the imax see the imax version no
way home shares the guys not matt
murdock charlie cox was right charlie
cox was right charlie cox charlotte cox
is always right charlie cox had a theory
of i'm not sure that's me i think that's
me you guys i'm gonna make a call
yeah i'm gonna drop an easter egg video
you didn't see his trailer reaction
charlie cox was telling the truth yeah
charlie cox is a youtuber now i don't
know it was weird to me because when i
saw that image that was going around i
was like still kind of looks like but i
guess it's not his body just looked too
big fair enough yeah well what what
threw me for i think that guy feels
scrutinized for his torso and his hair
that almost feels so awful and how does
charlie cox feel being known for the
poor guy all right thank you the
incredible thing yeah yeah we noticed
jay sawyer shang chi kind of reminded me
of a live action avatar the last
airbender netflix take notes that i
think that's very apt comparison um two
episodes away from finishing the show
and yeah the one of the very first
things i ever said when watching this
and i feel like it's even more apparent
the second time around
is that it really moves like a
live-action anime in a lot of ways
especially with the way they handle
flashbacks like
like one prime example that felt like
anime was when xiling and shangshi are
fighting each other in the ring and then
before shailene delivers her like final
blow to his face regardless that's right
slow motion yeah go to a flashback and
i'm like that's so animated that's right
no you're right you're absolutely right
i didn't even think about that
yeah it's very anime that movie the
dragon was definitely water bending yeah
he's water been in the [ __ ] of that
super soul sucker absolutely
that guy's love handles you bunk that
charlie cox there ain't that true remy
fox cam k
uh john once you read this one man with
the rings the shield and the hammer i
think we can all agree that weapons that
return to the user are friggin awesome
oh like the boomerang
i agree with you about the rings by the
way i thought the way they did the rings
was pretty dope in terms of degrading to
the fight i just wish they did even more
of it of integrating the rings into like
actual fight choreography the way they
were doing in the final showdown between
chongqing his father that's fair you
know i mean i thought for the most part
they were still used really well it's
just it's weird how it's called in the
legend of the ten rings and but i like
how the
the way they use the rings
actually the best comparison is lord of
the rings of this like it becomes like
an addiction for wenwu of like in order
for him to feel free and have a happier
life he relinquishes the rings then when
he's thrust it back into darkness he
goes back to the thing he copes with the
rings to exact revenge and then even
chongqi when he's having a showdown with
wen wu
he's like
she died you're supposed to be there for
us but you chose those damn rings over
us you know so it is like the lord of
the rings for him as it's like an
addiction for him so i felt like the
emotional context of the rings was cool
rather than trying to do a whole movie
about
deciphering what they are because that's
what i thought was interesting about the
post-credits scene was i started asking
the questions i hadn't even thought of
when i was watching the movie like oh
yeah what are these things where do they
come from why are they here like i never
and my mind never even went there with
the movie because i was so pulled into
the uh the emotion around it was uh the
adventure
the adventure you got me excited about
an mcu crossover with lord of the rings
how dope with that that would be awesome
that would be fantastic
i just got rid of this one that's what
they wanted
they wanted
to be originally originally that's what
they wanted from thor and dr drake
ramore i hope that that shed some light
on maybe why some of the powers of the
rings might have been changed i think it
also after end game and everybody having
to learn like what each stone do i feel
like it would almost be kind of too much
and too repetitive to be like learn the
powers of these 10 mystical like for
re-entry like this i feel like it's
quite appropriate boyton how dragon ball
is it does it top man of steel for power
levels
i don't know if it talks
dude
i mean man of steel's fight scenes
definitely felt more dragon ball ask in
my opinion except for the kamehameha
thing yeah i would i would agree
oh yeah
yeah because they're like flying in the
air and thrashing him
well
they're not really doing that in this
it's like fluid yeah nothing feels
overpowered i love the i love the little
mario jump though with the rings i think
that [ __ ] is so dope with that's awesome
yeah and then when uh what's his name
the chongqi's father i've never i've
never tried to say his name
when woo but like when he in the
flashback sequence kills the guy with
the ring like a gun i always think
that's dope every time i see it that's
actually my favorite scene in the movie
oh yeah that flashback is my favorite
scene in the whole movie that that that
became the defining moment for why i
love uh like i was already like man he
might be my favorite villain but then
does it remind you of your childhood
yeah when dad took revenge for those
people that killed mom
no wonder she doesn't like many movies
what i love about that scene
when when when wu murders them
in front of him he immediately goes back
into sympathetic father to shang-chi
he's like you know what's the blood
exchange line the blood debt must be
paid with blood a blood dead must be
played and he's just like talking so
like caring and sympathetic towards the
child like hey we gotta we gotta do this
together because we're father and son
you know i'm gonna show you the way like
i love how i [ __ ] up it is what he
just did murders this guy right in front
of him that instantly goes into
like caring for his kid right in front
of him thinking he's really in the right
so i i thought that was really cool
total air childhood yeah bipolarism it's
not the same thing as like thanos and
gamora where thanos seems to have like
thanos i'm like he's always coming
across a little messed up where as when
woo in that moment i'm like oh yeah i
could totally see how a kid would be
like my dad still loves me and cares
about me
the thing about one woo is when wu is
like coming from a very genuine place
and it feels very human yeah exactly
that's what works about it 100
kmk uh
we're taking turns we're just going this
rotation reading chat so you went last
time yes
uh cam k thank you trevor slattery's
monkey monologue
is an easily top five mcu mcu joke for
me i want a trevor katie jimmy woo and
louis spin off show like yesterday
you know you know what i'll say that i
thought this does surprisingly well that
kind of mirrors the trajectory of the
comics
trevor slattery um introducing iron man
3 right as the mandarin originally
people were pissed off about that twist
it is an appropriation of a character
they acknowledge that in this movie
and they may they do they redo the
mandarin with wenwoo and i'm like that's
kind of like what they did in the comics
they did fu manchu it was like a fu
manchu essentially
eventually people were like this is
[ __ ] up we shouldn't be doing this
yeah we need to change the mandarin
around and do it right because america
the way america's handling this is not
cool and now and that's kind of like
what they've dealt with trevor slattery
where they've he was hated but then they
managed to make it work where it kind of
mirrors what happened with the comics at
least he's an asian though ben king's
half indian so
his he yes oh that's why he could play
gandhi that's why he could be mandarin
marianne johnson
has a theory in the chat in the live
chat says i think the uh that beacon was
being sent to rama tut and those are
kang's rings from the future which i
could see some kind of weird tie in
there also ragu siddharaman the
flashbacks of teenage shang cheese
training felt similar to 300 that's a
good call that's pretty sure and we're
on episode 18 of brooklyn nine-nine film
nerds just went up i'm gonna watch so
many saints in new work i'm a big
sopranos fan i'm gonna watch the
sopranos for the first time
oh we got some stream labs look out
horror cage is number one john you go
take this one all right
i really enjoyed it i love the beautiful
world they built especially tallow uh
simulu is such a great leading man and i
think he did an incredible job in this
movie looking forward to seeing him in
future mcu projects you really like
simulu i think he's incredibly charming
okay and he has some great dramatic
scenes there were parts of his
performance that i never thought he was
bad i would never say that um there were
times where
i would feel like the weight of his past
wasn't always
felt in his performance yeah
like sometimes it felt a little bit like
there were leaning too much into the
charm and levity of this modern day
portrayal of chongqi
and sometimes the weight of like this
guy was like he grew he didn't grow up
in like
this guy has like at least 14 years of
the most [ __ ] up isolated road press
life ever
right and he's just so like charming and
so and i and i know he's been living in
the states that he said for like 10 to
15 years by this point right
and uh so i get it
still though it was the kind of thing
where i'm really into body language i'm
really into what a performer brings with
like their past being inhabited i feel
like tony lung really brings that to the
role yes uh but there were times where
with simulu i was like is he just a
little too cool is he just a little too
you know charming where sometimes i
couldn't feel unless the scene was
directly about it yeah then he would
bring it for sure like i love his
monologue to katie when he's talking
about how he killed uh the actual guy
like i really like that scene but there
was a lot in the performance where
sometimes it felt a little too light but
that would be it would be a complete lie
if i said i wasn't always charmed by his
performance i can't say that i
definitely felt that monologue more the
second time around the first time i
didn't really connect with it the second
time again i think it had to do with how
we were watching it i wish bill pope got
closer on his face so he could see his
eyes better because he had tears in his
eyes he did and i didn't like really
fully feel that the first time i watched
it i felt it more the second time but um
i i like him in this performance but
there was nothing about this film that
made me go i want to see way more of
this dude in like a thousand other
movies well it's just like i enjoyed him
in this and i am looking forward to
seeing him more in the mcu but there was
nothing that captivated me about him yet
that makes me go i got to see him in
every single movie he puts out i think
it's part of that thing you get pidgey
put that position you get put into i
think when you become the lead of one of
these movies is to like half your
dialogue then becomes like prompting the
plot to happen and learning sure so a
lot of moments where i was noticing the
second time around especially it's like
oh if they maybe had given him like when
yeah when the moment calls for it and
breathes in what is written there i
think he does a great job with it and
sometimes i'm like you know you
maybe somebody else might have elevated
further those scenes where it's like
tell me more where are we going what's
going on you know
it definitely suffers from
overexposition i mean i think he really
carries the movie in the first half a
lot absolutely i think i think it's him
carrying it and i think in the finale
he's got some great moments with his dad
or dad you know yeah but for me was the
opposite i felt like i felt like his
father carried it into aquafina more
than him for me kind of yeah it's like
he showed up to do the cool action and
then aquafina and tony leon carried the
film otherwise i don't know man when he
first has that first bus fight
like that's what i'm saying it's that's
the action but the reason the bus fight
feels so cool is because he really sold
us on his personality beforehand of just
like this happy-go-lucky guy who's kind
of a slacker in real life yeah so when
he unleashes and you see how serious
he's taking it when katie's threatened
you're like oh damn who wouldn't want to
be this guy
and he really sells the personal comedic
beats of that scene like when he lands
in the chair next to that one woman or
like he grabs the laptop from the other
woman you know everybody lands on the
bus store he's like please open the door
there's such a big difference it was
saying the word please and not saying
please but i was like keeping it polite
yeah please
that laptop thing was definitely jackie
chan oh yeah the whole fight was that
was the most jackie champ fight out of
them all yeah and and i would say the
moment the death dealer too when they're
like hopping around with a knife i got
this next one yeah julian86
no it's
i'm sure we're expecting a giant screen
space dragon wearing purple pants to
show up at the end credits scene but i'm
willing to bet fin ping fang foom will
appear in this current phase of the mcu
when do you guys think he'll show up and
in what movie thanks is finn fang foom
considered offensive
is he yes the name is
okay
because the great protector is not a
portrayal of
i thought they were just renaming it
because i was like oh they just want to
call finn fang foom because of the name
but then you watch the movie and you're
like okay yeah the great protector is
not
just a completely different dragon um
but it would be cool to kind of get like
the villainous dragon in there in some
way because i thought they did a great
job with the mega soul sucker which
essentially was a leviathan right and it
was really cool to behold
i didn't think it to me it just felt
like another dragon and i i think you
can bring finn fang fuma in there but
from fangboom talks right
if i'm not mistaken yes
and that's where they draw the power
it depends you know it's like is there
an
is there is it necessary to bring finn
thing fume and because in the comics
finn fang fume and the rings were kind
of interconnected where here it's like
we we don't even unless that beacon was
it must be signalling in the dragon
dragon
the land of dragons is about to open up
well i think they're going to explain
that there is like an alien technology
to it and not really a supernatural
element to it yeah i think they're gonna
keep it sci-fi i think it's gonna be a
while before
um
before marvel commits to fully
supernatural but they're still gonna
keep us in the science fiction realm for
a while i could see there being yeah
like an updated version of finn fang
foom or something that continues having
a kaiju element to these moments that
name is definitely going to change
it that name will not stick to fun
i am not sending any of these jokes it's
just going to change the chopsticks uh
song
julian
let's all read julian's at the same time
one two three hi
hi
mark we have chinese blood in us yes
yes we do you have all the blood in you
from the dna yeah i think we got all the
blood you got everything
well our great our great grandmother uh
on mom's side is full blood in chinese
dude see
you guys are strong
that's right james clark second best mcu
villain behind thanos i'll take second
best i'm glad someone's meeting me at
least close to the top absolutely it was
uh really a love story about shang chi's
parents and how their love lives
on and how their love lives on in their
children um yeah no i i think i think
the whole movie's really about love and
i i think that's a big part of why it
was so effective was because that's like
the undertone of everything going on in
this movie is love you know that scene
at the end with the uh the lighting of
the lanterns and stuff i wish they took
more time there i know that they had to
wrap the movie up as quick as possible
because the bad guy was defeated but i
wish they took just a little bit more
time because the second time watching it
i noticed that michelle yo was giving it
her all like in this emotional speech of
you know saying farewell to these lost
souls it's like i felt emotional and
then it cut to the next thing already
i'm like yo like slow down a little bit
we lost a lot of good people i think i
think that's a big part of why um
i think that's a big thing that i've
heard a lot of people who i even know
loved this movie said that they felt
like there was stuff cut out of the
finale or movie the parts that were kind
of rushed in the editing process there
are a couple scenes on second viewing
where i was like i bet a scene went
there
that's because it's because when you get
to tallow michelle yo's character is now
introducing a whole new world
of like yeah they're soul suckers we're
not even gonna cut to the visuals we're
just gonna have these statues here and
i'm going to explain all this to you
right now and that's what we're dealing
with for the rest of this movie yeah is
this thing here which i thought if they
had done more to make you really wonder
if when woo is is
on the level or not like if they had
really played that up of like maybe he
is really hear it but it's so clear that
it's going to be soul suckers
into you god i want to pull jon
you're very welcome to and iman ashraf
ishraf says the rings are summoning king
ghidra which uh that's the crossover we
need all right
i don't know why the dragon's offensive
i asked why the dragon's offensive but i
don't know much about it wait in the
movie or no no no yeah why is the great
protector offensive to the chinese group
the
name is offensive not the dragon itself
okay yeah dragons are offensive
[Music]
uh flev doran flevy's back flebulous
hit that like button listen to maria
hammond in the chat yeah thank you if
you're enjoying this
hi guys
we're we're moving along people are
already complaining about their super
chat's not being removed it's okay guys
we got more coming your way we're almost
to the end of this first round of stream
labs hi guys flev says again came late
into the live stream shang chi was so
good such a great debut for a new
character the movie had such a good
balance of marvel superhero and martial
arts films at least 95 percent that i
saw because i was
late to the movie oh why you're late how
wait what time did you walk in man every
scene is important i feel like they you
there wasn't a scene in there
like if i were to say cut this south and
i'd be a complete rewrite of like like
how i was sort of feeling conflicted
about introducing the soul sucker part
of the story i was like do we really
need this part in here but that would
require a whole rewrite but for the
movie they told i'm like no i feel like
they kept every scene
they needed to keep yeah in order to
tell this story so philip doran you
missed the part with andrew garfield and
toby maguire yeah it was awesome that's
the thing i gotta give them props for is
like there are so many scenes many of
which have to be compact and i was like
for this kind of thing these are about
as
good as these scenes could possibly be
like well done sadiskal says get sung
helene uh in the next movie yummy
you know what it is
the model yeah she's a korean model i
never i met her once actually she's
really nice yeah i remember her she was
on some
she was a playboy mom she was a playboy
she was like some show that i used to
watch i remember what song highly
well i think it's actually sung hee lee
wasn't she on like the mortal kombat
show or something hey john if you see
anyone um spamming make sure to block
them all right first borg says who it's
brie larson i don't care
you know no one hates brie larson it was
weird being in the theater when
both times she shows up
because
when hulk shows up it's met with
whoa whoa and then it cuts to captain
marvel and i'm like no one's insane no
one's reacting at all
you know what though everyone's
apprehensive i watch everyone's like do
i let it know that i'm excited i watched
um how do you say the director dustin uh
the director's name daniel destin daniel
destin i watched his best in daniel
whatever his matter destined daniel
[ __ ]
exactly i watched his first film with
brie larson and that was actually a
really good movie and she did a really
good job which movie she um i forgot the
name of it she turned 12. that's the one
yeah
she did a really good job they both did
in that film right right so
she's a good actress she's just a
terrible captain marvel
all right that's your opinion i think
she's
the best captain marvel she's the best
captain marvel anyone could hope for i
think brie lars i enjoy her personality
believe it or not guys i do not joshua
jones i don't i don't really care for
her portrayal in captain marvel but i
don't mind her like in interviews and
i don't hate her vehemently the way how
everyone else
no we already read that one we read that
one all right all right trevor
slattery's let's go it's rhythmic
rhythmic you know what no
you know what now that you mention it
didn't the grandma's husband die and
they made a whole deal about it at the
beginning of the movie
so maybe
wait what's this about that um the
person who was killed was shang the
person who shang chi murdered
is uh i did think about that too yeah
see i thought that was the whole thing
and i thought that's how he became
friends with katie and i thought that's
what was going to be revealed he's
living with this family as penance for
killing he doesn't live with this father
no so i was hanging out with katie's
family as tenants for killing her kind
of like in falcon in the winter soldier
you know a winter soldier was hanging
out with the asian dude because he
killed his son i thought it was the
exact same thing i thought it was just
representative of them not really
believing in spiritual [ __ ]
because there's a whole line in there
why can't it be both
because i think it's a little too much
well no yeah because that's the whole
point of especially like with aquafina
her her journey a lot of it is her i
don't really get what aquafina's
arc in this movie is to be honest she
finds her calling
to what to be a [ __ ] avenger is that
yes yes she in eventually she yes
because she had no she had no direction
for the longest time she was just
messing around how is she both of them
because wong called her in she's got
something going on in her blood and she
got something
i mentioned the same thing i mentioned
well she is a dragon we you know you saw
ryan the last dragon right so um i was
i've been reading the eternal comic i've
been reading the internals comic and so
there is something that happens in there
where these two characters connect and
it's like oh it's like i've known you
for a million years we're best buds now
and it's because they did know each
other for a million years because
they're both eternals right and so it's
entirely possible that
she's got some kind of connection
fair you know
i mean wong made a point say to say you
too you got to come in as well all right
both of you you shot the dragon
well then you're absolutely correct
rhythmsy i mean it wouldn't be the first
time right i mean peter quill we you
know that after that dance off and
whatnot he held holds everybody's hand
at the end of uh guardians of the galaxy
they're like how did he survive that oh
it's just because of the power of love
no he's connected to a celestial that's
why you survived that so it's entirely
possible they do that again
suman deep maybe bought a chart
you really don't like this explanation i
loved aquafina i feel like you should
just keep her human yeah she i thought
she did a great job is it my turn now
he's in the chair
hi guys really enjoyed the movie best
mcu villain thank you yeah definitely up
there my fate my personal fate look is
he the most threatening or the most
dangerous no he's not but in terms of a
actor's portrayal of an mcu villain he
is hands down my favorite one combined
with what was written for that character
yeah for me for me it's uh killmonger is
my my top favorite and then him and then
thanos but similar things that work
about killmonger work about when it's
like it's it's that approach to the
marvel villain of like yeah i get this
guy i don't necessarily i'm not on board
with him necessarily but i get it a lot
is revealed about that personal yeah
frustration you know well i think you
get you just get a full arc of you just
get a full story of him and it never
felt rushed surprisingly of this guy who
was always
set out for world domination falls in
love has a family gives up the rings
wife is taken goes back to the rings
goes down a darker path pushes his
children away wants to win his children
back loses himself to the idea
uh falls for some type of evil deity out
there that isn't real in the term losing
everything like it's it's such a tragic
story and it's a complete story that you
get a witness at all and you feel for
him you know did you think at all that
it did it you know cross your mind
whatsoever after uh chongqi's mother
passed away or died after she was killed
that hi juliana the bad guys never went
looking for the rings
ian is like flipping the place apart
trying to find it
oh yeah i mean
i don't maybe they didn't know he didn't
have them anymore okay that's all maybe
uh just crosstalk
it was like right on his desk it was
like right there like they didn't they
didn't look at the place at all like
that's right you say who's number one
bill and i got crap on twitter when i
said that so if anyone else says that
i'm like yeah we're together does
everyone meet everyone said exactly what
i thought they were going to say you're
more than killmongering thanos and loki
i'm like guys you know i need to know i
need to explain it
you know i'll need to explain it
sorry um
there's always ways to bring him back i
think some people were disappointed as
dead and everyone can what is ketone
saying both is good but if i can't get
bateman or jaby for real i'm happy i
don't understand okay i don't know
jason bateman he knows joseph crawford
don't
know if you covered this already but
what did you think of the soundtrack
greg loved it i thought the soundtrack
was great i thought it wasn't ever
overbearing and and the way of how like
uh
sometimes when you hear music like this
in any of these movies like rap r b or
whatever it might sound like
they're just doing that for the kids
but i thought it actually a lot of that
work like on the bus fight it actually
worked so
well
that was that was score wasn't it those
the bus fights yeah but that was the
soundtrack no but it was working in the
way of like it was like kind of a r b
rhythm wasn't it that that
i think that was by the composer i don't
think that was yeah yeah i didn't didn't
use any like
actually they didn't use any sound yeah
everything was scoring this movie i
don't think they use anything there was
definitely soundtrack music watching the
second time i definitely noticed
like when he's walking through the city
there's music with the building when
they're when they first land
you mean like okay [ __ ] like that yeah
that's something i thought we were
talking about like actual scenes not
like
inserts here's a moment yeah here's a
montage little pop song on top
well the thing is for me like the the
score worked for the film but it's like
the music didn't stay in my head like it
did for you or for achara and watching
it the second time i was like oh i don't
even remember any of these soundtrack
songs the first time i watched it and i
realized why is because it's not really
meaningful to the film it's just filler
so that they can sell the cd or sell the
you know the i don't know i think the uh
i think the
the first half of the music in the movie
was really good you talking about the
score or the soundtrack
okay yeah the score was good i agree
with you i'm saying i didn't care for
any of the soundtrack songs yeah i
thought they navigated the mix back and
forth between those well although i will
say that the only soundtrack piece that
like really grabbed me was the anderson
pack song at the very end but but you
know i mean like 88 rising did a whole
thing to curate the soundtrack and
they're like there's a ton ton ton of
asian artists and rappers on it so like
i appreciated what it's for you know and
and as
switching between the score music i yeah
the second time noticed and was able to
uh appreciate that a lot better but i
thought the uh scores the soundtrack
stuff worked too nothing we're gonna
have if we're gonna have asian hip-hop
artists for this how come we didn't have
eminem singing for winter soldier or
anything like that what's up with that
bucky
did he really yeah
i don't remember
greg you're the hip-hop one between the
two of us how do you eat more as well
you can't but the better everyone knows
the venom nobody forgets the venom
i did more of that beat down on the
gangsters uh in the brothel type place
kind of wish i saw chongchi's mom fight
with the mobsters me too that was one of
my big complaints is that we didn't see
shanghai's mother fight i wanted to see
the fight up until she hits the ground
and then cut to katsu chongchi's face
watching her basically you know get
taken out did you notice also that when
they showed chongchi's mother
dead she had no bruises on her face she
was just basically it's like she went to
bed i was curious about what they were
implying there because he says you don't
have your powers and she clearly
decimates a lot of guys so i'm like is
the whole idea her energy or something
yeah i was like did she still have at
least a little bit of powers or
something like that to take out like
30 guys yeah all at once i got some
martial arts on her that's all oh yeah
but at the same time it's like when she
is dead it's not covered in blood or
bruised exactly it was some type of
draining of energy or having to pull for
some life force within her that was a
spiritual angle yeah um i i mean it
would have been cool to see the fight
but i think the point of that scene was
to show the uh effects on like i know
you're saying they should have done like
a hybrid of both where you see the
flight yeah and you get to see shang
chi's reaction as a little kid yeah i
was per i personally was uh content with
just seeing his reaction to it all
because it made the horror of the sound
effects that much more disturbing
because you're like [ __ ] is she getting
like brutally murdered right now because
that's where my mind was going
it made it more unsettling for me
speaking of cutting away how did you
jesus christ oh that's that must be
something what is that clp clp
um
that converts to ten thousand dollars
okay
but anyway that just distracted me for a
second um
so i talked to to sintel and courtney
about that bus sequence when the guy is
like oh i did some martial arts and he's
like videotaping it and streaming it
from his phone
did you all like that a lot
as a as a moment of marvel comedy i
thought it fit naturally enough into the
scene it was a little silly for like
clearly when razer fist steps up you're
like all right my guy it was a little
too sometimes that [ __ ] can pull me like
in the beginning it was funny because
i'm like these the whole world has seen
a bunch of crazy [ __ ] by this point yes
like they've all seen the decimation the
blip all that so they've seen a chatari
they've seen a whole bunch of stuff so
seeing people fight on the bus isn't a
big deal yeah but
but it is a little bit undercut when it
is like this guy is just still like so
cool and making the jokes when like half
the bus is getting cut in half you know
what i mean
i i like the second time i watched it i
was more okay with it but i hated it the
first time i watched it because i'm like
i'm just getting into this fight let me
be into this fight like why are you
cutting it away or like just let it be
you know it was really funny i i i liked
it a lot i really wasn't as bothered the
first time the second time i was like
that's probably the only other criticism
i walked away with euler's workshop says
they won't show a woman getting beaten
in a disney movie no that's not true
didn't you see the little mermaid come
on did you see black widow smash her
face in in front of harvey weinstein
yeah come on that's right
she got her ass handed to her by all the
widows didn't you see that little girl
get exploded and then come back
come on stewie
she also gets destroyed and what if yeah
yeah yeah there you go and uh and nebula
i mean come on she gets full on taken
apart she gets tortured oh my god i
watched i watched end game again
games
she gets like literally tortured and
it's it's it sounds awful so it's weird
i do i do now the more that i think of
it i do wish we could have seen that
like just a huge the problem is that
fight would have been 15 minutes but
feeding shang chi's mom and everybody
else uh evelyn
jorgera
rose from chile
i butchered your name but uh we know
where you're from wong has a nice
librarian job likes listening to beyonce
fights in an underground club and goes
karaoke he really is one of the best mcu
characters wong is such a wild card he's
so chill compared to who he used to be
like when we were first introduced to
him as this very strict librarian guy
now he's the most party-centric
character
like he doesn't give a [ __ ] about
anything he'll just go and hang out his
character is very
yeah he is like a wild card now to the
point where i'm like what
i can't i don't know what tone his
character strikes anymore yeah but i
love that i love the after credits scene
when when chiang chi is like or
yeah then they cut to the karaoke i
appreciate that he went
well because it makes him more he it's
like i still believe that wong is yeah
concerned with all the mystics that he
needs to be but at the same time you
know he can't be doing that 100 of the
time
i love the in the fight with the
abomination where he makes him punch
himself in the face i thought that was
one of the coolest things in the mcu
ever they like the humorous bits and and
personality bits they did with wong help
like that's instances to me of marvel
humor that's character based that helps
expand and add legitimate quirk rather
than just being like here's an unlikely
joke i gotta ask you guys in the chat
right now first off
if you're still here and you haven't hit
that like button please hit that like
button secondly
i gotta ask
that long versus abomination fight is
really not that much longer than it is
in the trailer you know it's like you
get some dialogue yeah and then the
fight goes on like a couple of seconds
more you know
so but that was a big selling point for
a lot of people too in that when they
were seeing you know abomination versus
wong people were doing breakdowns about
it all that stuff and then it doesn't
really you
the movie would be absolute like it
doesn't actually pertain to the plot you
know so were you guys at all let down by
the fact that it they didn't do much
with wong versus abomination or did you
find it satisfactory enough like what
you're talking about with the punch well
the sling rings i thought was a great
moment it's a good teacher the future
but did you want more out of that um i
may i i didn't think about it to be
honest with you i was fine with it
however now that you said that it would
have been cool to see wong do a couple
more of those portal punches like him
getting it in the gut and then to the
face every time you know abomination
tries to punch him that would have been
cool but i was fine with it it was all i
ever expected it to be really
long i thought it would be longer
i thought it'd be like at least like two
minutes longer it felt surprisingly
short-lived you know back when i thought
there was going to be a fight tournament
in this movie i think is right when i
yeah i would have expected more of that
but it is a good tease for um you know
what's to come because clearly he's
building some type of team like it
raises a lot of interesting thing about
the wong and abomination moment versus
the
in conjunction with the post-credits
scene is it raises all these questions
now
of what the [ __ ] is really going on
because why is he there like why why are
they there why is wang participating in
these fights why is he training
abomination why why like what is this
team that wong is like putting together
of sorts you know is it gonna link to
val from falcon and winter soldier and
black widow you know what it's all
linking to well the bigger question is
why does he have to fight abomination in
that ring
why can't he fight him anywhere else in
the world why you need money
to fix the same sanctuary
although
no there's a hole in the roof we can't
use magic to fix it um knox technology
right tech is next just a few days ago
park sioux june was confirmed to be in
the mcu films thoughts on this possibly
being confirmation of amadeus cho braun
oh my i am
i'm unfamiliar with this part
i've probably seen this person before
do you know who that is i have no idea
who this character is i think uh andy
lee brought him up too in the chat and
you're like totally yeah i was like yeah
100 man exactly i'm caught up today with
everything you're telling me man exactly
yeah
oh okay it was in parasite maybe we
should come back to that question while
john looks at it i don't see the dad and
parasite no he [ __ ] no way
oh okay foster lie foster lee
uh do you want to read that one or no
greg john other crowd that's mother greg
love you guys
i think you're getting me confused here
i'm greg that's john yes john you always
see it with iced coffee
and you've never had it i don't you
won't see me with iced coffee ever i
hate coffee greg doesn't like coffee
should
you try it maybe um i hate coffee please
white girl and lie to me i'm sorry is
this about shang chi
no
no it's not but i think shanxi would
have coffee every now and then
so yeah sure why not what is what about
shang [ __ ] okay what's up what are you
saying is this about the whole the
street yeah
okay we're moving on we're moving on
to knox texting
he had a cameo in uh parasite and will
be in the marvels according to wikipedia
okay i believe if i'm remembering
correctly as the guy who the main you
the main young man character gets the
tutoring job from if i remember
correctly in parasite okay um but thanks
foster lee try some iced coffee sometime
lexi jade john take it away all right
lexie jade how many times did you cry
during chongqi i cried three times i'm
sure you can guess the scenes loved your
interview on andy lee what a sick
journey
did you how did you did you feel
anything in when michelle yo said to
shang-chi about having to basically
confront his past he's like
you're you're a culmination of
everything from you know your ancestors
both the good and the bad you got to
face the pain or it's just going to get
worse something like that did you feel
anything in that scene because that was
an emotional moment for me
no i didn't feel nothing most of that
really most of them i thought she
brought such a compassionate motherly
presence there's a strong portion of
that movie where i'm like i'm not
feeling anything oh i love that so much
because it's like i feel like i feel
like especially in this day and age
where
for a lot of people i feel like a lot of
us have to you know deal with our
history like even us where i'm connected
i'm connected not now not these days
no one's dealing with their passions
we have a very complicated history on
our dad's side like going back
generations and so when she said that i
connected with that that uh dialogue
from her where she's like your
culmination of everything from your
ancestors both the good and the bad you
got to deal with that [ __ ] i was like
cool like it made me emotional
nothing wow
okay so that was one of my secrets i've
been in therapy for like 10 years movies
are my therapy
i feel like i've been doing that for a
long time
these kinds of montages always get me
though is when his dad was about to die
and it cut through the montage of him
all the way till he's a baby yes that
always messes with me of like even in
like compassion of the christ when you
see baby jesus running he falls down
mary goes to pick him up it's like
seeing like the from the parents
perspective
uh of their child like after they've
already grown up in a flashback always
gets to me i don't know why so that made
me emotional all right i'll give you
guys one that i was in the middle
nothing ever you two what do you mean go
for it and then just now
i'll like split the difference of your
emotional responses and i'm in the
middle
what was what was another emotional
assume besides that when he died
they're what okay look
look
i got a little misty-eyed at a random
moment the second time that for a reason
i have no idea why when chicken puma
showed up
with who chicken pumbaa the chicken pig
no no no no no
it was when
they're fighting on the on the um
what's not called the skyscraper what's
it called this is the scaffold the
scaffold they had as capital you got
emotional at the scaffold scene no no it
wasn't it i got a little misty-eyed for
some reason when i do we showed up when
when jai ling showed up
and like the sister
like caught katie and she starts like
running up and i'm like i don't know
what it is about this moment but i
thought it was so touching because i
really thought she was like ditching
them i just didn't see it going it's and
it's that thing of like that to me is a
big part of the like it didn't get me
the first time i watched it the first
time i watched it i was like that's cool
and i'm sure i'm the only one in the
universe who got a slightly emotional by
that moment but for some reason that
move that moment does get me emotional
of like look at her look at her helping
out that's so cool and then here i
thought she was backing out yeah that
didn't do anything for me
i'm like i know i'm like the only one
who would get emotional in a scene what
other scenes could was there for
potential to get emotional [ __ ] there's
a gazillion scenes i know i'm asking you
like
dying okay that one i already we just
talked about um
the mom dying yeah i didn't feel a whole
lot there uh
trevor slattery
it's just a performance i need to be
dead
i did love that joke honestly i did it
like even though you can you can see it
coming i i did really appreciate that i
cried i cried tears of joy is it funny
how trevor slattery was so hated and
then he comes out of this movie like
he's so weird he's so awesome yeah
well his delivery was just so good top
notch yeah accent yeah yeah i was never
like moved uh i i never i'd ever i i
don't think i ever came close to crying
uh during actual scenes that were
supposed to i'm generally a pretty big
crier if i feel like crying i'll just
let myself cry
but um not one to be like fight it [ __ ]
don't show anyone i let myself cry if i
feel it but i didn't actually feel much
bobby steven
right better films better film tss or
chongqi and why the suicide squad or
shanghai
by far for me i vote the suicides really
yup what about you um i think that the
suicide squad to me was probably a
it's an experience where it feels like
less stuff had to be cut and and less
things had to be truncated so i think by
an inch i would probably say i think the
suicide squad's a bit more of a smooth
move no but suicide squad yeah
definitely box office says otherwise
sure why not
well and i mean
like i love a lot of stuff about shanghi
and i really love what it does for the
mcu but there is a certain amount of
like i can feel marvel movies slowly
kind of breaking out of a chrysalis of
being marvel movies to being whatever
the next iteration of that is so yeah
there are times in shanghai where like
you know it dips in and out of being
like okay there's a marvel movie and now
we're in something kind of transcendent
and different from that yeah um whereas
the suicide squad kind of is not on any
mold
yeah except the molds of older you know
cinema films not just like superheroes
type films yeah i see that i like shanxi
way more i think more i think audiences
generally will like sean chimor i um
but like generally audiences will
for me
uh to me it's
an easy answer
and you've watched and you've watched
both twice i watched well twice both in
theaters um but no there's a lot of
people there's a lot of people who don't
um
didn't like suicide squad and that's
fine i'm gonna use the restroom for this
next video
all right yeah stick the microphone with
you
hot mic
hot mike in the rest let's get through
all these super chats where he gets back
okay all right
i was a little closer for this now while
we're here john yeah we'll be right
front and center hey guys i was
wondering if you've seen the toaster you
don't have to be sorry it's our opinion
no um
like that's uh so i i get
i guess so i i think it's so stupid to
climb down people's throats for having a
difference of opinion
on like a show that where the point of
it is to do that but yeah but if in real
life i'm like it's so stupid to do that
artistic
interaction is that everyone's
experience is a bit different yeah and
then like
it's easy to say like oh i prefer
suicide squad more than then that's a
whole video and then i'm gonna dedicate
the next 30 minutes to explaining why
yeah um but they're by the end of the
day they're very different movies so
it's kind of weird to compare the two
and i'm like they're not the same yeah
they're so different
thematically tonally stylistic like
everything about them is so different so
i'm like it's kind of weird to want to
compare that's more like i would compare
shang qi and the show iron fist way more
than i would compare [ __ ]
you know well yeah
i mean graphic novel adaptations comic
book adaptations means like way more
broad things than it used to it's like
you know comparing a jane austen
adaptation to an adaptation of lord of
the rings both are based on books yeah
but they're very different books
fan added chat hey guys i was wondering
if you have seen the toby and andrew uh
i think i saw like a pop up in an
instagram feed but i kind of scrolled
past it really quick because i was like
um
just wait till it becomes more official
i've seen it in a pixel it's like i
already believe they're in it i'm just
waiting now i'm just like i'm waiting
for sony to show me now yeah yeah i'll
i'll read a leaked report way faster
than i'll be like show me the leaked
image reaction compilation all stars um
get sung highly in the next one yummy we
read that already does she still look
good
that that uh
let's i'm sure she does a quick google
no no no it's fine
i'm sure she still looks great
trey cersei okay here's their ranking
one guardians two infinity war captain
america first avenger well more than uh
winner soldier soldier i'm gonna jump
down i'm gonna be a hypocrite
and jump down your throat for not having
the same opinion as me
thor ragnarok and uh shang chi
that's a fair list i i would say minor
is for sure end game and guardians of
the galaxy one are my top two uh
and you know and i got i'm like the only
one who keeps iron man in his top five
i'm like the only one
right no no one else
not as good as iron man too am i right i
think iron man is i think iron man is a
solid film that is a solid like
well done heroes journey tale of just
this like it's a solid arc and i'm like
there's a reason why i catapulted the
mcu right away it's like the perfectly
solid first step yeah this i feel so
much smaller now yeah but i think it's
like solid anyway stephen uh thank you
trey thank you for everyone who's been
contributing so far and make sure to hit
that like button main thing we asked hit
the like
uh stephen
toff i started watching recently love
the videos oh thank you very much happy
to have you here
uh john frankie
these vids are incredible and fun keep
up the great work really appreciate that
john frankie we we
we do what we can mr ratcatcher two when
we're getting revenge on the iron gang
in the restaurant is engraved in my
memory forever a blood debt must be paid
with blood love your work guys
yeah awesome scene that is my favorite
scene yeah you know what i made sure to
watch the second time around was um
before the guy flies at the mirrors on
the wall to really focus on the mirrors
yeah because the first time i was
looking at the at uh chongqi's reaction
i'm like oh wait there's a thing
happening over here before the guy flies
in there he does that twice in the movie
the director what's that the the mirror
shot where you think you're looking at
the real shot like
well actually no it's it's a different
kind of mirror shot it's it's when
aquafina first sings hotel california on
the scaffold and then it pulls back and
then you're like oh we were looking at
the reflection yeah
yeah i thought that was really cool yeah
those are cool
it's a great scene he's got specific
style yeah um
johnny cam k it's your last year getting
your phd you're just a couple words away
from finishing
your year-long dissertation
and shanghai needs a computer shield
yeah man that was an impactful character
beat what is that woman gonna do she
probably failed and her life is ruined
maybe she was set up as she's the main
villain in the next one
he could have been a doctor she's like
max and [ __ ] amazing spider-man too
what does that absolutely that's what's
happening here okay let's talk about
that for a second
what did him using that laptop actually
do you know what's funny and the first
time i watched it i was like uh jackie
chan and then the second time i'm like
yeah
what did that do you didn't need to
destroy that woman's
laptop in the fight it was meaningless
like it would have been better if he
like used it to smack someone i feel
like
jason bourning yeah yeah something like
that like it he literally just took it
to let it get sliced and then tossed it
back to her but it wasn't a shield
because he went right through it he saw
that the dude was just cutting the bus
up so there's no way he thought that was
actually going to stop the the momentum
of that you know
that's fair that's fair so
[ __ ] this movie
no more love for sean squad's better
exactly no more love for
you
all right
uh okay go enjoy doing your work my
friend
death dealer could have been bad i mean
i i hope andy lee gets another chance in
marvel to like play an actual character
because the guy can act and he's funny
as [ __ ] yeah annie is a really funny
performer he was wearing a mask
yes
he was wearing a mask while in that
outfit is this a ryan george
he was wearing a mask
but isn't that awful like it's hard
enough doing fight scenes that it as it
is and that ninja get up yeah and on top
of that he's wearing a mask underneath
that all right yeah and he's still
flipping and doing crazy ass [ __ ] i
thought that was awesome nitpicking much
nah man
in terms of a fight i was thinking about
that laptop cost a thousand dollars for
that poor woman yeah
not if it's apple and i mean
and and also those words that time spent
cost even more
yeah i did hear that like it was payback
for making aquafina feel bad i mean
there's some i did see an obvious iron
man 3 now with the it was the extremis
is the name of that yeah the guy
fighting and yeah extremist or with the
the vip
yeah yeah yeah
yeah that makes sense that's what um in
the fight new rockstars
oh i haven't seen any rockstars videos
yet yeah
any of them what's with all the haters
all of a sudden they're all coming from
you know geeks and gamers yes they heard
we were streaming they heard we were
streaming
[Laughter]
is in the stream labs thank you so much
i'm glad to see you happy for the asian
representation and i'm also happy that
shangshi oh good geeks and gamers can
hear this uh and i was happy that shang
she had some romanian representation
florian montano
montenew
is razer fist let's go he's technically
born in germany from romanian parents
but still cool is he is he he's ivan
drago's son right yeah i did when i was
watching the second time like
wait a minute i know this guy from
somewhere
i don't remember that film very well
like i watched it and i just completely
blocked out that fight just trim his
beard blocked out the fight he's he's
not just in one fight he's in like he's
in the box he's in many scenes
i don't remember him at all i don't
remember that film very well other than
the training sequences like in the pool
and the desert that's all i remember
from that film i'm glad that most people
who are coming here are really enjoying
this movie
did you how did you feel about him in
the film because i did i was like when i
watched the second time i'm like why is
he in this movie why isn't it an asian
dude all right i got a nitpick what's
that i got a nitpick let's do it
pick that nit i'm declaring nitpick
before you be dick pic knit dicks
when his car is being taken
he's sitting at the security system
watching everything happen yeah i'm like
and it's and it's until they're driving
off but he's like that's my car
like wouldn't you have noticed the
second they walked in
were you not watching for them second
they went in there yeah you would have
noticed it
that's about my only problem with the
razer fist other than that he's kind of
just cool henchmen with a razor fist
he did exactly what i thought he would
do in this movie i didn't i didn't think
he'd be a character i didn't expect
anything from him no yeah no in fact i
think he was there more than i expected
yeah i only expected him in the bus
chase he was more of a distraction to me
i thought he would just be that one
fight and then move on any time they had
a ninja with a white dude
under the mask i was just a little bit
distracted for some odd reason
i mean it just shows the power of
influence that this white man is willing
to follow an asian guy and move out to
this compound in the mountains but y'all
you guys saw you guys saw every time
there was a ninja of white ninja right
like you guys saw that also like even on
the scaffolding fight there was a white
ninja in when when he goes when he says
my son is back and everyone like bows or
something like that what i saw white
ninjas in there too i'm like it's not
just we were all wearing eye blacks but
no it reminded me of martial law this is
the same thing
too woke
did you enjoy seeing you and juan the
film
who you and why
oh the the older guy with the who who
taught aquafina how to shoot yeah i
didn't realize who he was until i saw a
breakdown and then i lost my [ __ ] about
him and he watched his new rockstars
let's see here dead dead now did we read
this one den of lippy ippy lippy
yes jaby and greg and john let's go
my favorite trinity i loved the scene
where aquafina shot the bow because it
was predictable but perfect at this
moment yes it was how many generic
cliche things were predictable but
executed in
a way where they felt good zero that's
how much this one was the only one
i loved it i thought it was great
you know that's a really good question
it made me happy and i feel like it's a
very broad question so it'll probably
take a while to get to a good answer but
like there yeah like what's a good
example of a cliche in is it just this
movie for your question or any movie
because yeah like a cliche where it's
like just the execution of something
predictable makes it still great
uh
i feel like she can do no wrong it's all
it's all about the context of the scene
now it's like one thing predictable is
freaking
okay
it's obvious that the great protector
wouldn't die yeah right like if the
great protector dies and they [ __ ]
lose the whole movie right
but i remember the first time watching
it going
[ __ ] we're gonna kill the great
protector because it looks like he's
gonna die yeah yeah they're doing such a
good job on that fight scene with the
dragon that it was having me going like
daddy who killed this dragon right away
um so yeah that was so silly by the way
what he's like i don't i'm not gonna let
go of you again i'm like the great
dragon the great protector is about to
die yo let go of your sister deal with
the bigger problem
i thought that was i thought that was
very silly she would have died though
but this affects billions of people if
this dragon goes
but it's this she's going to die anyway
she's going to die anyway if the dragon
doesn't no no this way but didn't you
see the movie by doing this he was able
to have her live and everybody else live
you know what okay turtle's in the water
what are you
yeah that whole woke talk i think is so
stupid with this movie uh i'm like what
do you mean how dare you cast all asians
there's certain channels that just
managed to find a way to spit everything
into just like completely eliminate all
context around the conversation and just
zero in on a line that someone said and
then go this is all this just
i don't want to make the stream about it
now but what walk talk i'm confused
no not you no i made some joke and now
it's got barbie anything different make
fun of people who like spin way too many
things that way anything demonstrating a
modicum of diversity but um okay so um
one of my favorite lines is someone in
the chat was just bringing this up one
of my favorite lines is uh when tony
long looks at the guy who's been
training
uh aquafina
and
he says i like you better watch the way
you speak to me young man yeah
that is such a lived in line in the way
he says it is so cool because yeah you
forget like oh yeah this guy's been
around forever and i don't know i just
haven't seen that in a movie where this
guy's clearly like an old person he's
talking to yeah and he references a
young man yeah and he doesn't mean it in
a mocking way he means it in a sincere
way he's genuine he's genuinely way
older than this guy yeah the calm young
man i thought that was so cool so cool i
agree with you that was one of the few
scenes where the green screen was
obvious to me though i think the thing
with uh the sister though i can meet you
halfway because i did think it went on a
little too long as they were trying to
flesh out the moment of like no i'm not
going to abandon you you're going to try
to make an emotional scene out of it but
i did get a little anxious when i watch
it like
[ __ ] man we're going to
the great protector dies we're [ __ ]
we're all dead
yeah
so yeah one of those things young man
all right but yeah the young lion young
man line is one of my favorite lines in
the movie i love the great line yeah and
then his reaction too
he didn't know what to do with that yeah
mario pr you can only pick one to be in
shanghai too gently or jackie chan love
you
jackie chan
jackie chan i don't know what's up with
jet li but he was in the mulan movie and
a lot of people didn't even realize it
was jet li well jelly's incredibly ill
yeah he can't fight no but he doesn't
need to fight he just needs to be there
and say something but like everything he
did in mulan i i guess it's because he
was i guess it was because he was ill
no but just happily every couple minutes
but just having that presence is is
enough of a nod for people like if you
had jackie chan show up and not do any
fight scenes i think people would still
be happy if you if you're just talking
sure sure yeah yeah i think uh
i think um
um i think jackie chan is the one that
makes the most sense because jackie chan
okay we gotta walk open the gates what
you gotta understand with jet li is
jetley doesn't choreograph his own fight
so usually his choreographer is a person
named corey ewan who directed the first
transporter movie that's right so corey
ewan is his main choreographer where
jackie chan invented a style and he
invented a form of fight choreography
that is obviously being homaged
yeah so it just makes a billion times
more sense beyond donnie yen beyond jet
li beyond samohang beyond all of them
that the one you bring into the shangshi
movie would be jackie chan just
contextual speaking
brad allen was the second unit director
andy lee his big inspiration is like all
about jackie chan so i'm like jackie
clearly jackie chan is the main one
who's referenced so and you're wearing a
jacket yeah yeah yeah
someone a disney fan in the chat said
that so i was like yeah
that's why you bring on ciao and fat you
just surprised everybody you could bring
chocolate
fat absolutely everybody off
recently revealed that he wants he's
giving all of his money away to charity
when he dies it's already set up when he
dies all his money is going to charity
no one in his family is inheriting it
he's like that's the whole the money's
not for me it's just i just want the
best way to live life is just how to
live it you know relax and stress free
i'm like you made a career out of
shooting people like that
your biggest mammography is you gunning
people down and
here you are talking about like
what a selfish move
giving his money away give it to your
one kid no that's that's what [ __ ]
do throughout history is instead of you
know like these rich dudes who are
barons and who are you know not that uh
that he's a rich baron but you know they
build parks and and you know other
public fixtures to make it seem like
they were great so you haven't heard of
that land in hong kong
i want to go every ride feels like a gun
everyone stands that's it for the rhymes
exactly
the ride of the gun
do you know flippy if you look at
eternals it feels like a different film
as it has this tone and pace that seems
interesting then chiang chi was pretty
cool practical visual visually
compelling and structured well working
techniques together and then there's
black widow
yeah
i mean
i'm curious to know because it seems
like these are all falling on a
different scale of the practical to cgi
scope and i feel like shang qi arguably
did one of the best jobs i've seen in a
while while like still being like i can
tell you need a lot of cg for this
hey john
but
uh i was also like there were times
where i cannot tell where the real
effects end and the practical fights end
and the effects begin in a shang qi
whereas like in black widow there are
times where it's like oh okay it's act
three and we're just all in this big cgi
sky thing now
and then eternals i imagine we'll have
like tons and tons of like trippy cg
yeah
john you handled that question perfectly
let's move on
again flippy oh yeah and like i said
last time how's the soundtrack
oh you got all of them okay enough with
the keys and uh were they rings or
bracelets bracelets they're bangles
a bangle is a kind of bracelet yes
thank you sean
they are ring-shaped bracelets
i do hoping that we do see them do a
little bit because i mean i feel like
you're eliminating something really cool
from having you know 10 rings and each
ring does something specific
and then you kind of just i love what
they did with it in the movie but i'm
hoping they like unlock even like oh
there was even more potential with the
rings that they realized it's got to be
like all for one where like there's
secret powers in each ring but then like
they all come together to perform one
for all sorry yeah one for all but
they're more bracelets yeah you would
call that a bracelet if you were to go
at a store
if you went to hot topic by the store i
shop at weekly
he was like oh those are bracelets i
think originally they were actually
rings and then they got changed into
briskets for the film it seems as well
that's that is the case but it seems as
though in the movie their resting state
is ring is like bracelet size but think
of it if they change size so that they
can all fit up the bevel like you know
the the flaring of a bice of a forearm
then they could shrink to ring size then
they should get like cleft rings then
they should get the lip ring
how about gages you gotta get really
creative
a kick sends the ring into somebody
is on house arrest he's got an anklet on
this time freedom greg taking wenwoo
number one villain comments like
personal compliments
hell yeah of course i do okay that's
they are they are that no oh joe
and again yeah flevy d the rings are 100
celestial tech i'd be
uh in the chat for someone saying that
and i would assume that's why i'm not
thinking it's uh you know a lot of
people are like is it collected i'm
thinking no i'm probably trying to tie
it into like [ __ ] eternals or some
[ __ ] right like that's probably they're
they have to keep it a little focused
either eternals are king it's got to be
somewhere tied into that uh flev doran
uh i arrived late right when when when
yingli started fighting dancing okay she
kind of the right time and my defense
move was at 11 30 and i arrived at 11 40
but usually there's like 15 to 20
minutes of commercials where the actual
movie starts oh wow you got [ __ ] over
man yeah usually there's 20 minutes i i
work off that 20 minutes all the time so
frustrating like the one time you show
up later expecting the trailers to be
there that happens to me every time yeah
ava
thanks for the super chat
hi oh sorry if i asked her if i already
asked but you think tony outshined simu
yeah definitely if yes do you think uh
that's a bad thing because
well you see and also oh my god i
thought greg and john were submits for
the longest i feel dumb you thought we
were siblings
what no it's over here yeah that's right
don't you see the recipients um
well i think the thing that balances is
simu's in so much of the movie like 90
percent of it where tony long is not in
it as much so he doesn't completely
overshadow him and there's a lot of
scenes where
tony long is not with semu
so i don't i feel like tony long steals
the show any time he's on screen yeah i
feel like he's in a movie almost as much
as simulu
probably because a lot of a lot of
chongqing is flashbacks yeah so
but not most of it
well most of it but he's i feel like
he's on camera as like an adult this is
when i'm starting my channel called
screen time where we count who has no
screen time
screen it's actually a channel idea i've
had for a long time anyone want to take
it go for it it really feels like
something it really feels like tony i
want to start a channel that just breaks
down it fact checks every time somebody
says the first half hour of this movie
and then i'll go and see was it really a
half hour or was it more like the first
hour
how good is your time perception while
you're well i know i know plot beats so
well like the obvious mid point of this
movie is is when when woo shows up with
that's like break it to midpoint off
your typical hollywood script after he
fights death dealer yeah how did you
feel about his sandals
whose one moves
[Music]
because when he shows up that scene
you're talking about when he shows up i
expect dude to be in boots or something
like that like he's just nice he's got
all his others hell of his other dudes
are in sandals he's in boots he's the
boss so he wears the sandals oh my god
is this why you don't like the suicide
squad
because they're all wearing scenes
i think i mean yeah i think that tony
just to go back to that question i think
he just gets the juiciest stuff to work
with in the movie it's like the trouble
is often with any you know hero and
villain saga is like the hero is
something of an every man which can
often make it more relatable but also
less rich in terms of what they have to
do whereas yeah like when woo is the
richest character in the movie they were
like here they're like we they [ __ ]
him up in the comics we need to do this
right yeah so we're gonna do it so right
that that it out
people talk about
popcorn hello i loved wenwooz what's
that speech about his name do you all
know why your parents named you the
names you have have a good day oh do you
know um aquafina's chinese name
in the movie
i thought it was when will also
he says it's like ren renwu or something
it sounded so much like his name
and so initially i thought it was like a
joke or something i could answer your
question
to stay on track
before we start going all over the place
uh yeah i'm named after my uncle gregory
who passed at the age of 12 which is my
dad's brother my d my brother is named
after our grandfather
john
his parents looked at him and said give
him the most generic white man name
and they said that his grandfather had
a dream
bosses handle their business in house
slippers
i was just given a white like when
you're a white baby they just come by
with a label maker and they put one on
steve matthew mark luke john yeah
yeah we've done all the biblical names
uh
throw like
throw a fred in there or something just
to mix it up
back to matthew mark luke and john man
mark luke and john
all right let's see let's check back in
this sauron abraham says i wish they
explained the powers that low people had
was it chi or nah i mean they had the
wind bending and the water bending
i think it helps that they don't fully
explain and they also had the dragon
scales
it would uh it would you'd pigeonhole
them if you explained what it was they
have a general sense of mysticism yeah
yeah you get the idea yeah
their disposal but then you deal with a
lot more like [ __ ] rules that you
gotta be obedient to at a certain place
then you gotta flush out more when
there's already so much world building
in this movie hi
uh so yeah something like that
wow so many supers
all righty
where where is it where is it i'm
getting back we did can we flash to this
page really quick john before bringing
back the chat
all right let's bring it back up cool
thank you guys for hitting the like
button i really appreciate it thanks for
all you all for being here this is a
pretty pretty solid turnout i haven't
paid attention at all to the how many
people have been here or anything like
that this whole time so
literally i literally
literally block it so that way i could
just focus on the stream i think we're
here
yeah that one
um david gandy david
gandhi
david gandhi david gandhi's a friend of
ours
morning guys love the overall feel of
the movie differentiating itself from
past marvel movies can't wait for zawa's
eternals excellent job with your
interview with andy thank you very much
yeah we wouldn't have found we wouldn't
have had the the same position if it
weren't for you david as great as
eternals looks i can't help but be
honest with you guys right now i'm a tad
concerned that it might not be a good
movie i was concerned about that too but
i'm still very excited like um we'll get
back to the stream live don't worry uh
but yeah no i i am i'm excited for it
and i have a lot of faith
um the alien bad guy or the
the one that's holding up angelina jolie
yeah looked terrible i'm just wondering
tonally how it's going to be that's more
like my like tonally it's weird the only
thing's up i'm concerned about the most
basic [ __ ] with the turtles which is
tone and pacing that's the one part
where i'm like i feel like the director
would be at major odds with marvel about
how to do this movie yeah you know uh
none of that none of the jokes in the
trailer really moved me
i kind of like though i'm coming to that
movie for the comedy
it's it's whatever to me yeah but
overall i just love the concept so much
i think it's so neat and so i'm very
excited nonetheless i do have that
concern but i'm excited about the
concept if kevin feige didn't really
talk about chongqi but he is that
excited about the eternals
i feel like that means it's either gonna
surprise everybody with greatness or
surprise everyone with really not
greatness
i i usually i j generally have can you
guys hit that like button too when you
get the chance
please pointed it out and i was like oh
[ __ ] there's that many people watching i
thought there was like 500 there's over
a thousand
i won't tell you how much over but
there's over a thousand people in this
chat cool that's good to hear um
hamsa omar i love the film my only
problem every time i speak to someone of
asian background just want to bring up
the movie and say how much my respect
for the far east culture and history is
rekindled wait wait what your only
problem my only problem every time i
speak to someone of asian background i
just want to bring up the movie yeah i
get that feeling
that happened to me with crazy rich
asians every time i saw asians sitting
next to me at a restaurant i'm like yo
do you watch crazy rotations yeah like i
just there's a compulsion because you
know maybe you watched it because you're
asian but it's like you're dealing with
your pseudo inner racism because look
why should you have that compulsion just
because they're asian you know right i
can get away with it they're supposed to
care about exactly i can get away from i
don't know
i can get away because all asians are a
monolith yeah exactly
and there aren't distinctions between
them exactly we all watch the same thing
one big community right no no no i see
with forks there aren't different
countries that make up this one big idea
yeah we have now
uh okay look guys i said i'm a tad
concerned about eternals i didn't say
there's gonna be [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
welcome
the first time the first two times i saw
that trailer i was like this looks
amazing and oh my god and then the last
time i saw it was like probably the
sixth time i've seen the trailer i was
like actually you know might be a little
bit worried about the tone and pacing
that's what happened tim friedling is
asking if we're asian we are half asian
i don't say half chongqi's out we are
full asians
1 16th mighty choctaw
um
you'll get blue beetle uh dream restored
yeah you just got uh miguel from cobra
kai didn't he just get cast as blue
beetle pure filipino that one fear
filipino apostle 7
donating to point out that in the dark
was a really good transition song after
acadia is told the truth and is brought
out of the dark of shang chi's truth
oh hell yeah okay so there we go an
intentional soundtrack choice i guess i
i guess that might have been a subtle
choice on the director's end because
the lyrics to that song really didn't
stand out to me then it's not at all not
even a little bit funny enough the
second viewing was the time where not in
a big way but every once in a while i
was like i'd catch a lyric and be like
oh yeah okay this relates a little bit
yeah without being too too on the nose
billy the kid lawrence from blind wave
the editor there real rejects trip to
ohio to collab with blind wave
when
um
why don't they come here
yeah don't you see it'd be much easier
to fit four [ __ ] in this studio
than in their gigantic ass studios built
to house 10 people at a time on camera i
think it'd be so much funnier watching
four more people crammed in here
more people on their wide frame lens we
can put a round desk in front of our
square desk
yes reading on super chat comments wish
i could give 10 likes give 10 likes
jared wrote different accounts
abomination has always been stuck in
that form in the comics that's the
difference between hulk and abomination
not made clear in the uh he did go like
all out at the end of
the hulk movie so he he he might have
gone too far when he's like i want more
give me give me more
i want more
uh yeah that's my favorite emil blossom
line that's true
i like how he um he answered a question
i had an hour and a half ago
uh let's see here trey cersey a moment
of silence okay thank you trey
silence z shot media in a shanghai
sequel is it possible we would get a
tease toward towards the iron fist the
realm of tao lo reminds me a lot of
kunlun in the comics where iron fist
trains i've heard that a lot god i
really hope they don't bring finn jones
back
why
i think we need to unpack that again i
like finn jones in the way i like taylor
lautner
like
i think i like watching you try yeah
yeah you don't have to look at him like
you know i mean so it's so amusing for
me to watch act
and uh i'm like dude you got like the
role of the century uh even if your show
got cancelled i'm like but you you
i'm like oh yeah i want those olympics
characters to live on
not really offensive especially after
shanghai i'm like you know you need
people who can fight yeah and uh iron
fist is supposed to be iron fist comics
wise
is often in the top five of marvel
chongqi is usually number one in marvel
fighters but iron fist has to it's
important it's important that you get a
guy who can fight
all right z but uh no i mean i would
still like them to bring back iron fist
i think it'd be cool
star prod take it away johnny if at the
end when when wu died shang chi held him
in his arms for a little longer having a
flashback of his mom's death that would
have been uh traumatic enough to be a
catharsis of his character's arc i feel
like there's so apparent what's going on
with him in that moment that i didn't
need anymore but a lot of people feel i
feel like a lot of people needed more
wait his mom died
who went woo his mom probably died of
thousands of years yeah
it wasn't obvious that his mom died
she just went to sleep for a long time
exactly
officials there's gotta be a way to
resurrect the mom that would have been a
crazy post-credits scene wouldn't it
well i mean if something can suck souls
out and stuff like that maybe there's
like you know a way that we can bring it
back and it'll go wrong yeah you know
what uh on that i actually really like
that it was so final every time like
someone's soul got sucked out of them
and like i thought after the major the
mega soul sucker got killed i thought
everyone would never get restored but no
they're like they're dead they're gone
yeah this is a battle with cost yeah i
thought that was cool because you know
you're so used to especially after end
game you're used to things just coming
back
uh i'm gonna ask her this question in
the chat really quick um i think kingpin
is gonna be in spider-man no way home
and it hasn't leaked yet he's the lawyer
[Laughter]
um
let's see yeah they should bring colleen
back that'd be cool let's see here uh
michael
no no no official official sahil
hey guys just want to say love you three
even
okay even the white guy hey i love the
film can't wait to watch it again after
walking theater i can't decide where the
better knife fight shang chi or captain
america the winner well i think the
knife fight belongs to the winter
soldier the knife fight itself
but the shank chief fight was cool
there were parts of the way that fight
was directed though that i wish
like the with the death dealer
there were some parts of that shot that
fight that were too overhead
like coming from above where i'm like i
can't really tell what's going on it's
the second time i'm watching this fight
you know what i'm talking about when you
find death dealer and then oh you talk
about the camera the camera angle i
didn't like that camera angle the camera
angle was the part that was kind of like
come on it's a death dealer and shank
she just keep the camera profile i did
think about that actually i had that
same exact thought the second time
watching i'm like why is the camera
above them i can't appreciate yeah the
intricacy of the choreography as well
that was frustrating i'd have been okay
with one cut away to the to the top
angle but they do it a few times yeah
let's just get through this fight as
fast as possible now we're nitpicking
yeah no well maybe that was a moment
where they had to step double no
like for shot for
very similar yeah because like if they
have an angle where you can't really get
a good look at his face it's entirely
possible it wasn't him so michael
rodriguez uh can i probably say that
horribly
can i get a training montage of
spider-man and chongqi there is a comic
recently that where shanxi and
spider-man are
fighting each other team i'm not i'm not
really sure what but i do think shanxi
and spider-man would be an interesting
mix in fact you know who's also in san
francisco
venom
[Music]
just started flim school and whenever it
gets cool
and whenever it gets stressful you guys
it's a major super chat thank you dude
yeah holy crap save that for one of your
projects
uh whenever it gets stressful you guys
are there to give me fun and laughs my
question is what do you think is the
future of the ten rings organization
sorry if you got this question earlier
p.s john you're a
ugly abomination god damn you messed
that up oh it's a girl so thank you if
it's a gay guy they'll say that about me
but if it's a girl
no we actually haven't gotten this
question yet um but yeah i think we
could all say john's a cutie john's
definitely a cutie that was the question
we hadn't gotten uh yeah we think so
uh but
okay that is a great thing no one's
really asked about this and i feel like
a lot of people don't really give a [ __ ]
about it
where it's gonna go in the future the
ten rings organization because she
doesn't have the rings yeah so olivia
brought up right when the movie was
there she's like she doesn't have the
rings what
the whole reason the guy could conquer
goes around like
yeah i mean there's a lot of
to be fair like the mandarin in the
comics is usu was like a big was
essentially iron man's arch nemesis
he and because he was more than just a
fighter he was actually this highly
intellectual like
superior intellectual being as well and
we don't really get that side of when
woo in this movie you see some parts of
strategizing and whatever and figuring
it out but he's really uh more
they
don't really focus on that side of him
so
they don't really the way they establish
the 10 rings dominating is because he
does have the rings and he is the
biggest threat but you see him often out
on the battlefield as well using the
rings order to dominate so can they i
don't really know what the threat level
is or
it's like it seemed like the post credit
the first one was for the future of
marvel and the second one was for the
future of the shanxi franchise right and
what they're going to do there so i
don't know maybe she's going to be a
villain it's going to be a debate about
like no i can make the 10 because
because in the comics the mandarin um
when it comes to the ten rings he really
it's a form of control because he thinks
humanity's messed up in the way humanity
operates so if i can you know if they
live by like a narcissistic controlling
pathway if they follow the way i think
we should live then we'll be happier and
cool so maybe she has a bigger plan or
she's just trying to make some fight
tournament thingy
happened like eric voss had that
prediction in the post-credits scene
breakdown about possibly getting some
like tournament movie going like that
and that's maybe that what they've been
teasing and i'm like that would be cool
to watch like more lower level and like
not like the lead mcu characters but
smaller ones like going this tournament
that would be really awesome so i would
like that but
i wasn't as excited by the like
the way they shoot that scene i'm like
oh i should get this like
like you know like oh [ __ ] goosebumps
but i'm like wait a minute but she's had
the rings how can she be threatening
well it was pretty impressive that she
managed to get all those girls on board
like within a day and all know the same
exact form yeah yeah it's true
you know you know she moves quick
or maybe we'll get a 10 rings
organization tv thanks for a good
question man someone was saying in the
regular chat lewis tan as iron fist yeah
be great i'm convinced greg and i hung
out with louis tan when he was young
and he we were young yeah when we were
all kids i'm convinced we hung out with
lewistown i believe he smacked my ass
once without my permission we gotta get
him can't you joking yeah
no because we hung out we hung out at
philip tan's house
for like a whole afternoon and i'm
convinced he was there with us i just
don't remember like obviously you look
different when you're a grown-up
i'm sure he was there no no one looks
different
johnny b wonder if eternals addresses
whose head is nowhere
could be that would be absolutely
absolutely could
i mean it's that would be another thing
that we could then look back
so many phases ago i mean guardians was
the guardians of the galaxy one was the
first one to introduce the like actual
show like a moving celestial
uh and the collector's little television
that's what we call those screens the tv
yeah damn how you all get to know celebs
we live in l.a man
they're everywhere just walk outside
you'll see britney spears and madonna
just making out i'm pretty sure i'm
pretty sure it'll address who nowhere is
but uh yeah when when we were
when we were kids uh my dad would talk
to everybody and anybody and philip tan
who's a stunt coordinator former
stuntman was one of those people that he
made friends with philip tan is louis
tan's father and greg and i were in a
short film that philip tan directed um
it's always sunny in philadelphia yeah
i also always say sunny at philip
i also saw lewis tim with his dad once
at gymnastics olympia because i was like
flipping and stuff this is before
lewiston became famous he came in just
like shooting videos of some guys and
stuff like that dude
what's up i don't think we're
celebrities now i feel like we've been
celebrities for
a long time and we're just finally
getting the recognition we deserve yes
that's right sure we'll be celebrities
soon enough but we're we're just getting
to uh you know household name first
so you gotta pass the infamy percy
tremblet happy monday i noticed that
doctor just a heads up we are going to
try to end this stream in about 15 to 20
minutes okay happy monday i noticed that
doctor that dark strange is trapped in a
dimension that looked a lot like an
infinity gem you think he's in agatha's
brooch no
no do not think that at all
i don't think he's in a power stone
either if agatha was that had a
capability of something like that
she would have won his ass yeah yeah she
would not have been
on his first day using chaos magic no
straw what prime do you think chongqi
going to give us the wolverine costume
in the future mcu movies
why would it be shanghi that does it why
not just the respective standalone x-men
franchise that is to come in the x-men
in the mcu i think that's where we would
get it right
that's what i want is wolverine doesn't
wear any classic [ __ ] in the x-men movie
but when he goes to shanghi world then
all of a sudden he's in blue and yellow
i want to see him in a kimono now uh
abhishek
i love the trio bro brav bravado keep
him coming here was the thinker do you
think how few marvel comics were kind of
racist back then they need to develop
those characters with time in this day
and age yeah no absolutely it's going to
always be that way that's the way it's
always going to go it's not just a 2021
woke thing it's a thing that's the way
the world works the way time's involved
and then the entertainment industry
naturally evolves too and goes [ __ ] we
got to be more sensitive and reflective
of what people really want because
they're aiming to satisfy the masses as
much as possible so yeah i think it's
always going to be that way it's not
going to [ __ ] change
ideas it's going to change but
like because especially nowadays studios
are so plugged into the way people think
and feel via social media that it's the
way it's always going to go well and
think about it like every generation you
know you get more and more
you get closer and closer to the world
through what media is available so you
know think about it like 50 years ago
you had your news reports and your
newspapers and now
in the last 10 to 20 years you have
everything is visible and so it only
makes sense yeah that we would just
continually update
how we see
i should turn these off right how we see
the world
so yeah especially with these characters
i think it's important to acknowledge
where they came from and how that
happened but then move forward and yeah
i personally would have been fine with
fu manchu being in this movie yeah as
played by nicholas cage like in
grindhouse
that would have been perfect
all right because it's not racist if we
cast a white guy
uh all right i think why don't go
don't go down gumball reaction no down
down down
this part is what i remember
okay yeah so then
that one that's where we are all right
then we are back to our ba flev doran
flebulous doran don't have much else to
say can't wait to see what awaits
chongqi in the mcu guys hope you had a
great rest of your day and oh and oh
jaby i've been thinking about
what trolling my glasses and do laser
eye surgery how does that feel
i think that's a reference to the
glasses i was wearing last time
yes it is yeah how was it i think he
should get at least he should get a
laser eye surgery with us can he borrow
your spectacles when he needs to recover
those are dope ass sunglasses people
were mocking me for it but i love those
things
i like them personally gumball i thought
they were sexy as hell
gumball uh i am black
and loving
sorry i'm black and am loving all these
diverse directors this year can't wait
for chloe zhao's eternals and james
wan's malignant this year who's
everyone's favorite director doesn't
have to be a person of color haha but
james has been around a while i mean
james wanted
asian favorite current directors name
four
john woo was one uh dude who did broke
back mountains another one he's on the
lead he did the hulk movie oh he's doing
four oh my god he's almost there yeah
he's halfway there
the guy who did the fast and furious
series
kevin tantra kevin
dustin daniel crenton all right we got
five
[ __ ]
all right you win you won this one yeah
suicide behind the camera you've seen
them more than in front of the camera
so um yeah i think my favorite director
is
is martin scorsese always has been
always will be
just like mel gibson and braveheart
i was just thinking about mel gibson's
line from braveheart when you said that
uh what
always have always will be blah blah
blah anyway uh dino floppy
we're moving on here oh i guess so yeah
can you like favorite oh crap i just
lost it sorry it's okay no
mcu ranking top five number five
infinity war number four winter soldier
civil war doctor strange incredible i
mean end game
that's funny wait okay infinity war
winter soldier
civil war doctor strange
incredible okay all right all right all
right
ah
oh but uh shang she's not in there okay
racist racist [ __ ] totally racist we
cannot put it in our because
we're asian so we can get away we're not
putting on our top five
but if you don't then clearly you have
an agenda did you hear that uh scorsese
said that shanxi was definitely cinema
yeah he did he loved it he said he said
this is definitely cinema
it sounds like you're going on an
adventure the whole time
feels like you're going on a ride the
entire time martin score says he comes
to the theater with a stack of slips
that just say was this cinema and
there's a box for yes and a box for no
and then he signs it
leaves it at every movie yeah he watched
it six times really yeah score says he's
overrated as hell i know tell me about
it taxi driver a good fellow
yeah he's overrated especially because
like
he's not even faded in his grip on how
to make a great movie like so many other
prolific filmmakers like where did he
get off so overrated that guy what an
[ __ ] hey
spike jones is another favorite director
gumball i think he's pretty great
michael de souza
oh karen kusama there you go karen
kusama says hey i'm a huge fan of you
guys i've been watching your content
since the start
[ __ ] what's the first video you did
get out of here liar michael if you
haven't seen my coffee reactions you're
not welcome i thought that shang chi was
amazing
tony long and see me lou
see moo you know what simu you need to
change your name to make my life easier
is how you say it simuli but i gotta
slow down every time i say his name
seemu
simlu
were phenomenal can't wait to see more
oh my god he says it again seemu
in the future he's awesome have a great
stream thank you so much my friend
that's glad you feel that way
what i'm michael de souza i'm glad he
feels that way about senior leader i'm
glad people are appreciating him i like
i for me i just want to see him in more
mcu films but not necessarily like i'm
not excited about him
for non-mcu films at the moment
but john said that has something to do
with it just being an expository have
you seen kim's convenience
a little bit have you seen snake eyes
that was amazing
best movie ever asian representation am
i right
uh jossie hey guys big fan greg hope you
had a good b day
it was awful
drunk driving accident happy for the
asian community for shongxi
you think the next super hero race
should be hispanic
are their hispanic hero in marvel if so
who the next is gonna be either indian
or pakistani i am so sick of this virtue
signaling yeah
let's just tell our white characters
stories not shoehorn the rest of the
world's experiences
only reason they are doing things is
because of virtues
well we kind of have we have miles
morales
is what uh
yeah
uh yeah i would love for them to be
hispanic i think that's uh
yeah we don't really have that do we no
not yet
not that like readily comes to mind
that's not the blueprint we got america
chavez uh in doctor strange too as um
america
so
gomez is her name
yes i don't have a great grip on how
those x and c maybe i shouldn't have
defended martin scorsese in this marvel
silver surfer silver surfer i just want
to know
what your opinion is on quentin
tarantino then yeah i i thought that's
something as soon as i saw that i
thought
miss
yeah okay all right let's move on den of
but i would love to be yeah
personally shanghi is the second best
comic book movie this year for me
out of three what i feel it missed was
emotional connection
hey we got a criticism here boom corner
says i'm not alert that sibling bit not
great
the father's portrayal was negative he's
the bad guy i wish i just wish there was
more weight which marvel has issues with
mostly
wait what's he saying about the sister
then with his sibling connection sibling
connection not great which seems to be
kind of a common i felt that criticism i
liked her i didn't um i i know i did not
i but i felt like i was the minority
there i felt like
most people who saw the film liked her
but like every time i saw her every time
i heard her say a line i'm like just say
less things this stream will end in on
time uh today because we have a lot to
film for other stuff so yeah uh but yeah
i i think uh i don't know i i i like the
father [ __ ] i guess the sibling thing
kind of missed the mark a little bit but
uh i didn't feel like they were siblings
the the grown-up versions the younger
ones i felt like they were siblings but
they're
siblings i i didn't think they were
actually i felt them estranged yeah they
haven't seen each other on like 28 years
and they have like a huge emotional rift
yeah
and like they were kids last she was
like a little girl and then then um and
then the next time i see each other
they're like completely different people
so they're gonna they're bound to not
feel like siblings there wasn't any like
fun sibling dynamic between them that's
something i really think could have
elevated that performance
you know like there was no part in the
movie where you know looks at her and
goes hey remember when we were kids and
dad made us beat up those people there's
nothing yes i mean there's nothing
there's nothing like
where they reflect together or like a
true emotional scene between them other
than i'm not going to abandon you again
yeah that was missing so i'm back to my
crime scene movie should have been
longer seeing some joaquin torres love
in the
live chat as well as white tiger being
good for latin representation dino
floppy
totally unrelated but will you do a
reaction from malignant on hbo max
loves the three of you from
the flippy boy thank you uh probably i
mean i really love james wan
yeah for great things about malignant
i'm not sure he wants us to watch this
movie with a bunch of lights pointed at
us
yeah the way we did for the conjuring
three i'm like probably would have
enjoyed the concert anymore without all
these lights
well that's what that lens is for we got
a special lens now thanks to this guy
yeah we can keep it more dim in here all
right
dino floppy floppy
well now that you said it i'm a gay guy
and greg you are not a cutie jesus
christ what a mean thing in the super
chat pachabi youth all right i'm keeping
this whole dollar
you should
you deserve it because i'm taking the
blunt but he's kidding he's joking but
jaby is i'm just kidding yeah he he says
jk but he's just saying that because he
wanted to get away with telling the
truth when really he's telling him
john is yeah i know john's a cutie no
john rides off his looks everywhere he
goes doesn't even need to go to the gym
[ __ ] [ __ ] john
it's just one of the few places i'm not
comfortable going to i'm sorry because
you exercise outdoors how great would it
have been if um
when wu
was eating mandarin chicken while
talking about
the origin of prop coverage
that would have been awesome
all right guys we're reaching near the
end of the stream here just a couple
more minutes we're just wrapping up the
end here i think there's just a couple
more what is marvel 1602 i saw that
pop-up in the regular chat uh it's earth
1602 that's where uh shanxi is actually
a black guy
really no no no no like what
anything's
all
possible
get a little bit more over here
come back all right we almost
we're gonna get the last of the super
chats and then we can cap off by doing
one more refresher of the stream labs
michael k williams died is that true
what
are you serious that's a that would be a
blow that guy's a great character actor
do you really
no let me look this up really quick yeah
john get us set up all right so we did
this one already this one we finished so
it's we're above that okay
all right that's yeah that's new oh [ __ ]
michael k williams died rest in peace do
they know from the wire boardwalk empire
i just started watching the wire i'm on
season two i've never seen the wire
that's a that's a this is an amazing ass
actor i know [ __ ]
i was i just saw him too there's always
that guy who i'm like he should be more
famous i know
he's been holding it down for so long no
way he's actually dead
ah restaurant oh a moment of silence
that [ __ ] sucks
um anyway let's go back to answering fun
marvel questions
i love the trio bro bravado keep them
coming here's a thinker do you think how
few marvel comics were kind of racing we
did that one we did this one but okay
hey abhishek thank you all then there
tensey rumor is greg made out with louis
tan and philip tan's house yeah
philippines uh-huh yeah there's a video
of it
lewis tan is a very attractive man and i
think that if he wants to take me out
sometime i'd be more than happy to i
thought he was perfect in mortal kombat
best actor ever good
jonah
when abouts do you think wolverine will
be in the mcu
wolverine will be in the mcu
when we stop asking for wolverine to be
in the mcu that's in kevin feige's like
press the button
it's been ready all this time they
haven't asked for it
ace in the hole yeah there you go yeah
that's when you'll come into play that's
not coming the foray thank you guys so
much
no more in the stream labs but i want to
make sure we're not there's at least one
more let's double check before we do the
final all right cool it's making sure
that we're going to stick with the chat
for a little bit but yeah man michael k
williams that's uh that's really getting
to me right now yeah man that's really
gambling maybe
didn't even know
stamina mc's he uh says he's omar from
the wire i
he did a really really good job in the
wire
man
he's in a lot of movies i [ __ ] love
craft country too yeah i haven't seen
that no he is like a veteran
like he's been holding it down for so
long
yuri 714. and weirdly enough somebody
commented earlier that it's idris elba's
birthday who's also on the wire that's
right yeah that's where he made does his
claim defend
bucky is my boy and it's the best
sidekick of cap kind of a nightwing next
to batman in my opinion thank you yuri
it's very relevant to the comments
yuri it's great having your opinions in
here man that wing is actually the first
comic books like character i really got
into heavily i love nightwing a lot
that's the only reason i don't watch
titans is just to get to nightwing there
i think batman returns is better than
the first batman
just i think so too rando spin-off
conversation that we're doing i don't
know actually i'm making sincere i
completely agree with you boom
i think batman returns is so much better
than batman 89. abhishek senator says
james won with a horror twist in the mcu
how about that uh it would be
it would be canceled and then sam raimi
would take over
yeah guys i mean
michael kate williams someone we gotta
remember uh
wire
lovecraft country boardwalk empire just
to name a few look up his imdb and
you'll probably find he's in like half
your movie collection versatile actor
yeah yeah so he could be present yeah my
god he was incredible he could be
intimidating as hell too
but yeah all right thank you dark horse
but guys we're to wrap up this stream
right now so let's do a speed round of
some questions and then uh yeah we'll um
say goodbye tim vreeling wants to know
what's everyone's uh number grade out of
ten for this movie
and the legend of the ten rings
ten and a half out of ten i i hover
between seven point five to eight
yeah
i think i think i think seven would have
been my my uh number the first time i
watched it and then now it's probably
seven and a half yeah yeah i'm about
seven point sometimes i'm an eight and
sometimes i'm just a solid 7.5 what
about you john
no i'm right in that like seven and a
half to eight kind of range what we're
on the same page we're on the same page
and you don't go to the gym
i i exercise outside
he walked up to the gate to get in here
i have
stuff to approximate the gym experience
but i need actual weights now i i get it
it's not approximating the gym
experience you know i get cardio in and
i have like
rubber band things that i use for
weight training that's what you call it
all right all right yeah you know and i
have a
weighted jump rope move let's go pick up
some [ __ ] in there
all right fine all that rubber band
strength you got i mean it's not as
probably good as having like an actual
set of dumbbells around that doesn't
matter you got your beautiful looks can
we answer the questions no no
i'm not getting mad at john for nothing
i've you know
i'll go to the gym
hey guys i'm here with everyone's fluids
what's up that's that's how you work out
i think we talked about everything right
with this movie pretty much we talked
about it like literally everything yeah
if anybody has spiderman trailers
do you think chongxie will be in no way
home that's a question no one's brought
up no i don't really
be in no way he's gonna be he's in the
secret ending unless it becomes that
like the that room the library of the
sanctum sanctorum becomes just like
where every other marvel character is
like walking past in the background or
something like if who do you think he's
going to have the best chemistry with in
a crossover movie
yeah
[Music]
i think
iron man
he's come back
[Laughter]
uh oh that's a that's an excellent
question who
i feel like one of the more youthful i
don't know i mean i want to be like
splitterman but i feel like one of the
more youthful like fun oriented
characters because ironheart
definitely
williams let's do it
let's do it
thor
maybe actually no i think even thor
would have good chemistry yeah i think
chris hemsworth would have great
chemistry with him yeah i mean because
they're both fun and buff chris
hemsworth definitely knows his way
around a playstation
that's true we should watch them just
game against each other the next one
actually jules saying uh um uh sam
wilson
um and i think that's actually not i
could call it absolutely i guess yeah i
can see that working out really well
dude and then he and bucky can you know
like have a have odds with each other
you know to who gets to be sam's partner
all right guys time to start saying bye
got a lot to film gotta get all done in
the next few hours
but uh stamina thanks for being here
jaylen bakaku dark horse you really oh
remy fox oh aquafina and shuri that's a
great call yeah varun jaby thanks for
being here followed get jaby on his
channel
youtube.com follow him slash around get
jaby starring achara kirk
min mom andez martinez remember bulldogs
we prefer doing spoiler talks live
because i never know if we're talking
about everything that people want us to
talk about so you guys help drive it
thank you guys so much keep a lookout
for regular uploads tomorrow expect at
least 12 spider-man no way home videos
this week
we'll catch you guys soon be well
everyone
thank you
crotch
is that what we're doing the crotch yes
everyone stand
but mine's not showing
right in the
mine's not showing end the stream